Oh, dude. It's just it's just the the big sweep. Why are you
mad about being called the sweeper? My friend's getting accused
of beating women. You son of a [__] [laughter] I
don't want any I don't want no drama with you, Nick Dioro. I'm
so confused. Trelogic in public wants you to believe, right,
that he's been trying. He's been edging. He wanted to talk about
this for months. He's scared of being called a sweeper. You acted
like I was a comically evil defender who's sweeping up for Turkey
to Tom before I even knew what the allegations were. It's [__]
He told me. He told me it was about me. You think I [__]
made this up? Bro, I had endless charitability for this guy.
Okay, so if you guys have missed it, Chud and Nicholas Yori have
been fighting. We did a video on it yesterday. I think where
Nicholas does have a point is saying that I think Chud is probably
referring to Nicholas when he's saying the sweep could be on
But I think Nicholas infers a bunch of things from what Chud
said, okay,
that
just aren't really there. I wasn't sure if we were going to do
this segment. I went back and forth on it for a while. I didn't
really think I needed to do one to be honest because most people
pretty much already agree with me. Before we get started, I want
to most people
when you when you block out of existence anybody who disagrees
with you. It turns out most people agree with you. We're just
going to go through this from start to finish and I'm going to
give you my side of the story. Now, I watched Chud Logic's little
crybaby response, the 2-hour version, and I commend DK editing
because he worked really hard to condense that down to 40 minutes.
You know how much random coping and seething at his own chat
that he had to remove? Tread Logic uploaded this video about
me today. Uh, well, yeah, last night actually. Um, I think he
expected me to respond to this or not respond to this, but it
was it was interestingly interestingly timed or whatever because
I was about to go live. So, this is the the the response to the
Chud claims from his stream segment. I'm going to take you through
it right now because actually, I think you're all aware of this.
He released my DMs. Fair play. Fine. I've released DMs before.
I'm not going to go and go postal and say, "Oh, it's super up
that you're leaking DMs." is the golden rule man. But what I
am going to do is explore these DMs because it was really stupid
that he put them out.
So just to get started here, let's review what Chudlogic has
released and I'll get into why this is significant periodically
throughout the little presentation I'm going to do with you.
We're going to come back to the screenshot a lot. So you can
see here on February 1st I wrote yo and then on the 14th of Janu
sorry January 2nd I'm I'm numbering this wrong cuz he's European.
On January 2nd I wrote yo and on January 14th I wrote hey I just
saw a clip of you saying that I don't like you anymore but you
haven't answered any DMs from me since September. Lmao I did
try to keep coms open. Now the context to this will become more
apparent as we proceed but this is how it was presented in his
stream. Then Chudlo Logic says, and I swear to God, he chose
to release this on his own for the brief moment while we're looking
at DMs. I'm going to cover that because it's it's blocking the
stuff. Um,
hey man. Yeah, I've had a lot on, dude. [laughter]
if you if you do this voice, then you'll hear the things Nick
wants you to hear.
and you rely on your audience getting very upset for you. >> Honestly,
it's difficult to even know what the deal is. We've gone our
separate ways in many ways and obviously it does feel a bit that
no one really likes me anymore from the commentary community
space. I do probably have some issues with some of your coverage.
By the way, like Chud
Chud said this, I feel like Chud read this out is he's just trying
to be real. I don't think this is him like being like, "Oh, I
really wish we were friends again." It's just him being like,
"Yeah, it seems like we're not friends, so I guess we go our
different ways."
But I don't want to keep talking about EHT. And honestly,
I've appreciated the things that you've done for me. So, I make
these snarky jabs from time to time just to see
is nice. Um, I don't think it's being nice. I think it's um like
avoiding conflicts.
I Yeah, I get I get why you wouldn't want to like do
I get why you would you
I get why you would write this way.
It's not just being nice though. It's uh it's >> compal
to you that I just blow up what little bridge we have left by
going full skitso mode attacking you. I guess I feel aranged.
which I thought was really weird because I said, "Hey man, you
just went on stream and told everybody that I don't like you
because you're friends with Queenman and um
you've ghosted me since September, so that's kind of odd, but
thank you for the random glaze, I guess, and you feeling people
sad about it." So I >> Wait, I have to I have to hear that.
>> Stranged, which I thought was really weird because I
said, "Hey, man, you just went on stream and told everybody that
I don't like you because you're friends with Quean and um
That's I I let I I think if we end up doing this, okay, if we
end up building up some kind of timeline here, that's what it
is. Okay,
that is really what it is in so many in so many ways. Okay,
it's
it's that Chud was close to Quimman and they all decided that
Queen was like super evil. >> You've got kind of odd, but
thank you for the random glaze, I guess. and you feeling people
sad about it. So I wrote back just to be perfectly transparent
with you. The conversation here soured my perception of you.
I have many friends in the online ecosystem that I disagree with
or who make different content than me. That was never my issue.
Despite this, I did attempt to keep the bridge open regardless.
Uh I don't Yeah, I don't think it is like that. And again, this
is totally transparently. We're keeping the bridge open. I was
keeping the bridge open. Again, we need to go find the So, he
says even So, going back to May, I think this is May of 2024.
Sorry, May of 2025 rather, right? When when they're having this
conversation, I think when we go back to that, okay, so that's
where Nick says he soured on Chud.
After that, you get Tommy C. I think it's after that. You get
Tommy C coming out and going, "Chud's a snake. Everyone hates
you, Chud." And Nick never says anything. Like it seems pretty
obvious to me
overall at least
that Nick
was saying these things to Tommy. All these things about Chud
being a snakeish. Attempted to keep the bridge open at all. He
was just using Tommy as like a mouthpiece for his opinion, trying
to get people to dislike Chud. And then privately behind the
scenes also talking about Chud. So he says, "I'm trying to keep
the bridge open." It's like, "No, you're you're not. You're just
like barely keeping contact with me.
It's just an obvious lie.
And we'll see because I think that's probably the biggest thing
to me is when I see Tommy C, a guy who's friends with Nick, who
Nick vows, totally friends with him, everything.
And Tommy C is coming out and saying, "Nick doesn't like you.
None of these guys like you. We all hate you." And none of them
speak up. I'm going, "That's you guys all putting that out in
public."
None of you step forward and say, "No, no, no. That's wrong,
Tommy. Don't say that." Not a single one of you says that. And
then you're going to go and say, "Oh, I tried to keep the bridge
out." "No, you didn't. What? The [__] out of here."
So then I didn't really respond to him. So he gets like more
and more desperate as I don't respond to him. So it starts off
with him saying, "So yeah, I mean that backs up my feeling of,
you know, being estranged.
It's all good. I'm not mad or anything. Um, well, things change
and people do different things." And at this point, I still haven't
responded. And how long was this? Was this like was this like
10 minutes? Then he writes, "Listen, man. Uh not everything has
to be some cat.
dude,
the It's very very funny. Listen, man. Not everything has to
be some catastrophic breakdown." Haha. I know you. I know you
are used to that. Yeah, man. Good luck with whatever you're doing
over there.
That's just like, "Yeah, it just didn't work out. We're not friends.
We're going to go our different ways,
right? That's I don't know why he's reading so much more into
this.
>> Uh but we'll go he's basically I think where this ends
up going is we end up leaking what the previous messages were.
>> Breakdown. I know you're used to that. I'm just like,
"Yeah, man. Good luck. Whatever you're doing over there, good
luck with whatever you're doing over there. Fine. Cool. No problem."
The interesting thing about how Chud leaked these DMs is cuz
it was very apparent to me while I was watching his stream that
he didn't really want me to. Well, he didn't really want to ratherly
after that stream
and I've archived it already. I've already archived it. >> His
chat like bullied him into leaking these DMs, which is I it's
it's really awkward. I don't know why people are acting like
I've got >> Oh, he has to run with this narrative, too,
that Chud gets bullied by his chat, which I mean happens. But
if you watch, I don't know how this works. In my in my mind,
I don't know how this works. Okay,
later in this thing, we'll see that Chud had spent like weeks
and months defending Nicholas to his chat, right? And Nick will
bring that up later in this stream,
but now he's saying Chud got bullied into this. I don't think
Chud so much gets bullied into things as Chud wants to do something.
He goes, "Oh, twist my rubber arm." And then he does it. Right.
So, it's like this whole thing where Chud both, you know, he
resists the chat. He doesn't like lean into it. He says, "Guys,
if you have a problem with Nicholas, go talk to Nicholas. Don't
talk to me about it." Like, "Go talk to Nicholas if you have
a problem with him." I like Nicholas. Nicholas is my friend.
Like, they all He defends Nick the whole time, right? Constantly.
And then and then you know they're saying leak the DMs. Leak
the DMs. And he's like, "Yeah, you know what? I'm He wanted to
leak the DMs." Right? If he didn't want to leak the DMs, like
when he when he wanted to be when he was close friends with Nick,
he thought Nick had his back. He had Nick's back, right? Didn't
matter what the chat said.
Now he's doing the twist my rubber arm thing. I just assume he
was going to leak the DMs. I I don't believe he got truly bullied
into it. But if he if you want to sell that narrative, I don't
think that really makes a difference. >> let's archive
everything. It's fine.
At one point he says, "My word is my bond." Which again, I don't
care if you're leaking my DMs, but I don't know why you leak
DMs where I look normal.
>> Why is everyone freaking out? Relax.
Relax, bro. Relax.
Why do people want to see the DMs so >> Why do they want
to see the DMs so much?
>> Why do people want to see the DMs? >> Keep in
mind, he's got these archived. That's why my new profile picture
is in >> I don't understand, dude.
It's not that deep, bro.
>> Did he say he archived the DMs? I thought he said he
archived the video, but maybe he archived the DMs, too. >> It's
not that deep, bro. [laughter] But yes, it felt very much.
>> Yeah, sorry. Yeah, Nick does talk about how Chud's like
gotten less funny or Chud's fallen off or whatever. It's like,
oh, you watch a lot, man. You watch a lot.
You've been watching a lot,
What the heck?
[laughter] That's a lot of stream time, man. That's a lot of
stream time. Running that all the way to the end here, buddy.
We're going to watch We're going to watch like every VOD. Like
everyone. Okay.
Very much like >> like you want to call this guy a chat
slave, you can because just watch, >> you know.
Like this is going to be the constant flow with Nick. It's that
I'm going to make some comment on stream. Okay.
It's like I'm going to make some comment on stream and he's going
to come angrily to me privately with >> Put a pin in that
one as well. >> Have a private conversation, resolve it,
but nothing's really resolved and there's still this underlying
tension. >> Apparently, I run to him every time he says
something about me on stream and then we resolve it privately.
And those messages were the first time that I realized he'd have
this problem with me about this and how it happened >> So,
this narrative is very interesting. I do want to establish this
early. Chud Logic wants you, the viewer, to believe that he knew
he was estranged for six consecutive months and knew something
was wrong, but he was entirely caught off guard when I told him
that there was something wrong.
How can those two things both be true?
I guess they can't like I feel like they could both be true,
but I I'm not necessarily going to say that. What I would say
is you you have like a feeling. Does anybody else get this? Maybe
I'm the only person who has like uh racing thoughts sometimes,
but like in a lot of cases, I'll have a feeling something's happening
and I'll explicitly push that down to to make sure that I'm like
I I'll just tell myself I'm you're overreading it, right? You're
overreading into somebody's reaction to something. You're overreading
into something somebody said. I just push that down because I'm
like, "Yeah, you're overthinking it. Just put it down. Make it.
It's just noise. Don't pay attention to it." And move on. And
95% of the time, that is like the correct decision. Like you
put that down. Yeah. Gay thoughts. Sure. Push down the gay thoughts.
Okay. Okay.
Yeah. It's like you you push it down, you just say, "Well, it's
not that important. I'm reading too much into it." And you move
forward, right?
I think that's probably that if I had to guess if that's what
he's talking about, that's what he means is he had like this
feeling but he's like ah that's like gay self-conscious unironically
gay thoughts like feelings, right? So you just you like kind
of push it down. You're like ah I'm not going to I'm not going
to let that ruin my day. I'm not going to think about it and
then you move forward and then you find out that you you shouldn't
have pushed it down. That was one of the times you should have
actually paid attention to it.
Funny you mentioned that because I'm having ruminating thoughts
as we speak. Yeah. Like everybody has this thing like did you
not go to like middle school? I don't know if my friends like
me. My friend just was like my friend just hung out with somebody
else. Do my friends even like me.
Yeah, you push that down cuz it's it's like yeah, they're your
friends. Of course they like you. It's probably that exact thing
when Chud's like 40. He's probably like, "Man, maybe these guys
just don't like me. Maybe they just totally abandon me or something."
And I do think he's got people in his community who say that.
Like these guys are you over there. Tommy C is talking about
you. Why aren't you doing anything about it? Right? And he's
like, "No, Nicholas has my back. No, Nicholas has my back." And
then he finds out that no, no, no. All those uh people in his
community that were saying that were probably more correct than
he wanted to let on >> for months.
For months, dude.
>> So, yes, I was estranged. I was aranged. None of the
other commentary guys like me anymore. and Nicholas said that
this issue with me for months that he hadn't really expressed
and just hadn't really kind of been honest about. >> Now,
now this is the one part where I will also sorry there's a couple
parts where I will I'll side against Chud. I don't think Nick
even necessarily makes this point,
but Nick does say like at some point they agreed to talk and
Chud never called the guy. Chud was like, "We can talk off stream.
I we'll we'll do a call and we'll hash this out." And then Nick's
like, "Okay, that sounds good." And Chad doesn't call him. Okay.
Now, on the other side, that could look a certain way for the
other side, too. So, like, I'm not going to I'm not just going
to say Nicholas's the only person who did anything wrong here.
It seems like if Chud wanted to keep that bridge open, he could
have been more proactive about it. Okay.
There there are places here where heed up,
but that's every conflict people ever have. Like, every personal
conflict people ever have. Um,
how bad is that? I'm not sure. So, we'll we'll go. I I think
I saw some of the DMs. I haven't seen all of them yet. So, we'll
keep watching. >> Now, again, I hadn't expressed these
issues. I hadn't been honest about these issues. I thought you
ghosted me since se Well, we'll get there. I'm getting ahead
of myself. We'll get there. I'm >> So, yeah, it was just
this kind of unending underlying tension
that was just kind of like
Wonder why?
Well, because he felt Well, you know, I don't know, dude. I don't
know. Because I didn't want to talk privately or something. I
said I wanted to talk privately and never followed it up with
him about this clip and about >> Wait, how could Hold on.
So, I didn't tell you there was anything wrong, but you offered
a conversation with me and you never followed up on it and you
were surprised that I was not happy with you for a while. Oh,
that's a weird one. Nick does make that point. I I think Chud
can't really be shocked that Nicholas is like kind of cold towards
him. Now, that's different from the Tommy C stuff. Okay. I think
Chud can't be shocked that Nick is kind of cold to him when Chud
offers the conversation.
Yeah. We we pointed this out already. Yeah. Yeah. We see he watches
all the streams. Um
but Nick can't be sorry. Chud can't be shocked that Nick's like
a little frosty to me if Nick was like kind of not talking to
him or not boosting his channel or whatever in in like not talking
about him at all, not professionally associating, that would
all be fine so long as Chud like has never bothered to reach
out and and like fix that thing that he said he would do, right?
The the problem is that's not all Nick was doing.
That's not all Nick was doing. If that's all Nick was doing,
if he wasn't spreading like gay rumors, if he wasn't trying to
like put this guy behind the scenes, then I do think that like
Nick's fine to be annoyed with Chud or to even be upset and just
be like, I don't want to talk to this guy. That's fine.
I don't even think he necessarily has to say he he kind of was
like, I'm annoyed at you. Now, what is he annoyed about? I think
that's where we'll get into problems with Nick. Okay. But at
this point when he's going to show this stuff, it's like, yeah,
Chud does offer. that about >> that happened around it.
>> That's a weird admission.
I'm malicious.
What do you mean?
>> How am I being What do you think? >> What do you
mean, bro? What do you mean?
What do you mean? What is malicious here? Me responding to Nicholas.
wait until I go on holiday to say a bunch of crazy about me to
make out like I'm like I'm an I'm Alex type bigger and then I'm
responding to it or me saying well hey here's a bit of a background
of how this came to be
how is that malicious bro >> you got to keep up the actual
topic here stop fighting with the chat I'm trying to get to a
point >> I am responding my word is my bond okay
my word is my bond
You guys just want to see DMs. You don't need to see them, bro.
>> Why does Chud Logic not want to show his DMs with me?
>> You don't need to see >> Why Why would he not
want to show his This is so weird. >> See them?
>> I think he just doesn't want to get into leaking them
overall.
>> We saw them. They were really damning. He didn't want
to show them.
Better question is when you were in Vietnam and I was supposedly
plotting against you, why didn't I redact them? Unless I wanted
you to have them.
>> Nicholas is going to show them.
>> I Okay. Did Chud redact his side?
Why didn't he redact them before he went to Vietnam? Unless he
wanted you to have them. Unless he wanted you to have them. Or
maybe he did redact his side. I don't know. Maybe he did.
Uh I I feel like probably not if I guess No, actually no, cuz
Nick has the screenshots, right?
I'm sorry. It's just like I don't Is that even an argument?
Very goofy.
>> When did Nicholas become so gay? Um I think he's always
been like this.
We Me and Queen were talking about this last night. Apparently,
when Sunday did his little did his little gay op on Nick, Nick
like called Quean, panicked about how Sunday was going to [__]
him over. And I know that Nick called a bunch of people about
that, trying to make sure everybody was on board with his side
of that narrative the entire time cuz he didn't want to he didn't
want to be like made to look like a sweeper or anything. He didn't
want any of that happening,
Like he was incredibly sensitive about this stuff. the entire
time.
So, I just I think it's very funny that
he's like he's trying to paint Chut out as this like very sensitive
person. He is very sensitive. He takes all of this stuff. He
hates anything that is like remotely imputing him in any way
from other creators. Like he he despises it.
And I'm saying he despises it to the point and we'll get to it.
The reason the thing he said basically that's um Chud Logic like
taking a true shot at his credibility and is when Chud throws
the joke out that Nicholas is sucking Ethan Klein's or something,
right? That that's what the stream is. I think it may when Chud
makes that reference and he's like, "Oh, that's you saying I'm
like a totally degenerate loser like lying shill." It's like,
"No, it's like laughing at your Ethan Klein coverage." I think
that's I think it's like it's laughing at your Ethan Klein coverage
and signaling that like, hey, you're kind of riding a little
too hard for the guy. It's like a light criticism, 50% criticism,
50% banter. It's what everybody does with their friends to like
get their friends back in line. You see your friend being a little
bit of like pompous jackass somewhere. You throw a little joke
at him, that's also a criticism. You get them back in line just
like, "Hey, we got to clip your wings a little bit. You're flying
a little too close to the sun, man. You're not being a cool person."
>> Hey, fine. I'll show it. pretty obvious. >> Yeah,
I'll show it. [__] you, Nicholas the Oreo. >> So,
there it is. Chud gets bullied into showing my DMs. And those
are the ones we just saw here. Now, I did notice that eagle-eyed
viewers pointed out that the messages that Nick said ruined his
perception of Chud were actually not one of the ones that were
included in the leak. And until it's released, Chud's acting
like Tom's accusers selectively releasing DMs.
So, you could say that, right? I think you could say that.
But Chud characterized those DMs. I wonder if I could find in
the transcript really quickly Chud characterizing the DMs that
he wasn't like putting out there cuz I'm I'm pretty sure
that with those DMs,
if I'm if I'm not
right, with those DMs, he just said what they were. He was like,
"Yeah, I basically I got in a conversation with Nicholas about
the the comments.
I He was like upset about the comments. He didn't like it and
I said, "Okay, if you want to talk about it, I'll call you off
stream." And then I never followed up. So, we'll see if that
characterization of like that exact progression is how it plays
out cuz I think that's how it plays out in the DMs. And so, it's
like, well, he didn't release them, but essentially what he said
about the DMs was true.
I don't know. Maybe we could find if there's like a little bit
there. There could be maybe he's, you know, sweeping for himself.
A little self sweep there. You didn't want to leak like quite
how how consiliatory he was with Nicholas or something. Maybe
you could argue.
What is this? I said Oh, I said years ago that Chudlo Logic is
a spineless snake and faces faced endless targeting for it. Despite
saying my piece and moving on, I was a fixation for him and his
crew for years. Glad to see he's facing the music now.
Is he?
Is he facing the music?
I'm gonna say, okay, I'm just going to say it pretty pretty clearly.
Okay.
[gasps] I get super concerned if I was in like a fight with a
big creator, like another creator that's like, you know, maybe
half my size or something, and Stardust is on my side. I'd just
be like, I'd immediately go like my stomach would turn a little
bit. Like, Stardust, Stardust is your boy on this one. You had
Stardust and Tommy C on your side for this one. Okay. All right.
All right. I'm feeling comfy. Anyone else feeling comfy? I'm
feeling pretty comfy.
Um I By the way, there are things that are like wrong with Chud's
response or or how Chud handled this situation overall,
but I do think I think we work on this after we watch the Nicholas
video. We work on this. We figure out all of the little things
that happened along the way. All right. And figure them all out.
And that would be damning if that if Chud selectively released
DMs. That would be pretty bad. Now, Corn Toasty did say, "To
be fair, the way it's worded sounds like this conversation reference
might have been in a Discord call and not text messages." So,
even though this is all a terrible look for Chud, there might
not be any other relevant texts, which is a good point. That
is a possibility.
No, I It's actually impossible that there's not a relevant message
there. Nicholas literally highlights a message and says, "This
conversation is what put me off."
Like it's it's literally he's referencing a text. There's like
maybe like a 1% chance that that's the case, but I just assume
there's text messages there because he's referenc It would it'll
just be about Chud's explanation of what happened in those messages
in this previous conversation in May. how did he characterize
it versus how it's characterized by Nicholas or how it's actually
how you can characterize it if you read >> something here
but there's no there's no way that like this message that's highlighted
in yellow is publicly available like well not publicly available
but like accessible to Chud logic that he could have shown you
the actual context for
so that
>> I think Chud might have even said that the messages
are there he might have even said why he wasn't leaking those
>> what we're going to be going through [clears throat]
tonight because it absolutely was there he just didn't want you
to see it.
So, ladies and gentlemen, >> idiot, whatever. >> A
main thing that I want to establish with you for the context
that you're about to see is my understanding of Chud Logic back
in the day. And you must have seen these rants because I remember
them. And this is one example that I'm going to show you from
a relevant video. Chud Logic would constantly fight with his
audience because he felt like we >> Oh, the audience he
was scared of.
the audience he's petrified of
>> being a kid against each other and he wanted to maintain
our friendship. >> Chud Logic lives on an island. They
always his little audience members go and chase away every single
person he's friendly with. Uh and they want him to stay on his
own little own little island, make content by himself, and that's
just the reality of of what Chudlogic's content creation journey
is and will ever forever be as long as he remains audience captured
the way that he is.
So chud logic would go okay I
okay
what what part of this there's a quote from from Nicholas somewhere
in here that he it might be later on and maybe I listen to this
like I heard this quote somewhere he says something like DK Chud
standing up for DK with the whole like when they wanted him when
a bunch of people were pushing him to fire DK was like the most
principled thing Nicholas had ever seen.
Does Nicholas realize that like DK was the head of the chatters?
Does he realize that DK was like the number one? All of the problems
that Nicholas has with Chud
were literally like DK was the personification of those exact
issues you're describing now. And he's exactly who those people
were going out. Like that's why those people were going after
him for this exact reason. Cuz DK would criticize a bunch of
people. DK would get super
DK would get a little out of pocket about it. Okay. He could
say some super out of pocket about it, but you're literally the
thing Nick describes as the reason he respected Chud
is also simultaneously the problem he has with Chud. So I don't
I don't understand. I don't get it personally. >> Go on
these rants trying to like reel his audience in because he did
not want conflict with me. >> Right. But it just feels
like at the moment it's anything that goes against
>> So this is the clip.
No, I'm not bringing up Nicholas Doro's stream. I'm not making
it about anyone individual, okay? I don't [__] care
about your gay cam. This is also really Do you know what? Do
you know what? Whilst we're here, I'll also say this as well.
I'm so sick of you. >> Sorry. Sorry. As if to drive home
my point. DK in the chat. Dario has been credibly accused of
consensually being throat [__] by Ethan Klein. Okay.
As if to drive home the precise point I'm making. There's the
Oreo. Sorry. There's DK. the the guy Nick was like, "Oh, it was
so noble of Chuck to stand up for this guy."
But his his audience is like crazy. His audience is insane.
That looks That's a horrible look. That's a horrible look for
Nick. Gay.
>> My goodness. >> Utter Cretins desperately trying
to [__] >> throw a wedge between me and Dioro
because he's [__] sucking Ethan Klein at the moment.
Okay, >> I got issues with it, but you guys are so you're
like my brain with this. People in his chat are his brain to
try to get us to fight each other and he doesn't like that. >> Unbelievable.
Dude, if you've got a problem with what the is saying, that's
between you and Nicholas. If you've got a problem with something
that Creamman is saying, that is between you and Creman. I'm
talking broadly about the issues that exist that I've noticed
and you are trying to laser focus. All right. So, this is my
major issue with Chud Logic. I was under the assumption that
he wasn't lying. That he actually didn't want us to fight each
other. That he actually didn't like how his audience was trying
to pit us against each other and he actually he actually felt
like he was kind of in a bad way. That was my understanding and
that was clearly my bad. So now I'm going to show you the message
where I ran to him crying and oh my god I it doesn't appear that
I've done that. Boom.
What happened?
Wait, this can't be the start of the conversation. I was told
that Nick was in tears.
What the
Why is this a Reddit post from H3 Snark making a joke that they
referred to Chud Logic as one of the biggest sweepers of Ethan
Klein? What the
I thought I thought I was supposed to be a an emotional crybaby
that I was running to Chud Lodge. Oh, wait. What is this? Then
he starts sucking my dick.
Dude, I was absolutely raging yesterday. I hope I didn't cause
you any grief. Well, that's not exactly how he presented that
in the live show, is it?
>> I actually think basically
if you want to go back to like um
Dude,
I feel I feel like this is precisely everybody like Chud's audience,
I think this is like precisely their issue, which is super funny
to me as well,
Like I I think this is quite literally their issue is like, "Hey,
you you Nicholas is like a totally disingenuous rat and you're
trying to be nice to him cuz you think this disingenuous rat
[__] is going to pay it forward somehow."
Like and and it's never going to happen. Like if I had to distill
criticisms of Chud, it's that like Doro treats him like a piece
of and Chud just like sits there and accepts it and is like,
"Yes, sir. Yes, sir." That's that's literally that if you want
to go with the audience impression again, that's like how if
I had to like characterize Stylo's descriptions of Chud and and
Nicholas's friendship, it's not a friendship. It's Chud like
bowing to to Nicholas all the time.
So, I don't know where did the characterization come from that
that wasn't the case.
Might be why he didn't show it. Didn't want to show it to Stylo.
He was right. >> is that how >> it's not like a moral
failing or anything? presented this in the live show where he's
just like, "Dude, I was ab I was absolutely raging yesterday.
I I hope I didn't cause you any grief."
Yeah. So, this was the thread. I just thought it was funny. It
was the video, so it's a halftruth, I guess. Um, but yeah, leftovers
H3 clipped Chud's rant where he's like, "Fuck you, Nick Dioro."
>> Now, hold on, hold on.
He said you were upset about it.
Are you upset about it? and they called him Ethan Klein's biggest
sweeper, which I thought was funny. So,
>> wait. So, hold on. Now, we go to the next set of DMs.
>> From there,
>> this is
Where are we? Oh, I hit the wrong one. Sorry. So, from there,
I because Chud Logic has now brought it up. >> So, Oh,
because Chudlo Logic has now brought it up. No, you you brought
it up. You gave him the clip.
What do you mean? Because Chud Logic has brought it up. You messaged
him with the
You
messaged him with the clip. And he goes, "Oh, yeah. I kind of
went off on you there, bro. My bad."
And And what was your reaction to that? Oh, well, you've since
you're going to bring up that you were mean to me.
That's not how this works. If it didn't bother you, this wouldn't
be a thing.
>> I gave him the issue that I had with his segment. So,
he goes, "Haha, dude. We're absolutely raging yesterday. I hope
I didn't cause you any grief." And I said, "I know. I just really
don't understand you stoking the flames and taking shots at my
character if you're annoyed that people are baiting and trying
to make us argue. That seems fairly counterproductive.
But some of the stuff that you've So, you clearly thought about
it. You had a problem with it. So, where's the mischaracterization?
Where where's the mischaracterization?
I don't I don't get it.
Like, and it's, by the way, this is why the tone indicators are
bad, right? Is because he is going to try to launder like the
totally
totally like
accurate description of these DMs by Chud. He's going to try
to launder it through as as like Chud lying about this and saying,
"Hud Chud didn't show this so he could lie about it." And everything
Chud said about these DMs is 100% true.
That's what he's trying to launder through is he he's going to
say Chud lied to you where what's the lie you've talked about
is stuff that I've complained about too like people annoyingly
agreeing with Noxaku. So I don't know it just feels like a weird
game of telephone where a lot of assumptions were being made.
I think this is a reasonable thing to ask somebody who is publicly
facing and privately facing telling people that they do not like
when people are trying to pit us against each other. It seems
like a weird thing to go on a
Hold on. Okay. So,
that's
I don't think this is an unreasonable, By the way, I I don't
even think this is unreasonable. You could you could say this
to somebody in private. I think usually you'd expect it to say
in private, but they're they're burning the bridges, okay, completely
with each other. I think this is fine to ask somebody in private
to just be like, "Hey, you know, you see, but Chud's got two
problems here. He's got two problems." That's only one of the
problems. The other problem is he actually has tangible disagreements
with the way Nick is covering stuff. And that's the other side
of his audience is looking at him and oh did is this the the
parry clip of Chud opening up paint?
I don't think it matters too much. Is this what it is?
Oh no it's not. That's funny.
That's funny. Uh okay. So
God, they're both just describing their feelings a lot. I think
this is fine, but Chud's got two problems and he's only mentioned
one to Nicholas so far cuz the other one's awkward to bring up.
He actually has a problem with the coverage. He's got a problem
with it both substantively and
because I obviously, you know, I'm sure
I'm sure he's seen comments in like Spicy and stuff about from
Nic like people criticizing Nicholas's coverage of the uh Ethan
Klein stuff. Okay,
so he's got two problems. He's only described one. The other
problem is one that does make it like kind of compels him to
criticize Nick in some way, right? He is a commentator. He is
friends with Nick. To withhold his opinion when he disagrees
with what Nick is doing is disingenuous by his like standards,
right?
So, he's probably going to try to bring >> rant about it.
If this is something that you do not want, >> then Tread
Logic wrote something that is very interesting. >> He said,
>> "Yeah, I understand. I just feel totally ripped at the
moment. I obviously have some issues and disagreements, but I
can't reasonably state them without causing some stupid beef.
Wait, what do you mean stupid beef? I thought this was Nicholas,
WHERE ARE YOU? WHY ARE YOU NOT ON MY STREAM? WHAT? WHAT? WAIT,
what do you mean stupid beef? I thought this was I thought this
was Kino important content. And then he says,
>> Hold on. So he's describing the second problem, which
is I have some disagreements with you, but these two problems
conflict. I cannot I cannot help solve I cannot solve one without
exacerbating the other problem. Right? I can't fix people trying
to fight with you without making the problem of me not criticizing
something I think you're doing that is incorrect. I can't I make
that problem worse.
But if I criticize you, if I differentiate myself from you, I
make our friendship worse. So I have this this these two problems
that work against each other. So I'm talking to you, my friend,
about how I can solve that. Feels like tough to solve.
Is that confusing to anyone? It's super obvious to me what's
going on here, right?
Hey, I've got these two problems and solving one exacerbates
the other. >> Okay, continue. I can't react to your exact
takes without causing drama.
I I thought, wasn't the commentary community on Auggie stream
founded by the guys in the trenches fighting every little talking
point? I'm so confused. Tudlogic in public wants you to believe,
right, that he's been trying, he's been edging, he wanted to
talk about this for months, but Chudlogic in my DMs is a cowering
little who's SAYING, "OH, I DON'T WANT ANY I DON'T WANT NO DRAMA
with you, Nick Dioro. Ah, I can't even do this when I >> Wait,
is he complaining like now? >> The guy's in the trenches
fighting every little talking point. I'm so confused. Tudlogic
in public wants you to believe, right, that he's been trying,
he's been edging. He wanted to talk about this for months, but
Chudlo Logic in my DMs is
that's not true.
I mean, he says he has issues, but the the actual thing, so maybe
I just misunderstand,
but on that whole clip where where Stylo comes in, I could have
sworn Chud was like, "I was trying to be friends. I wanted to
be friends." Do we have to Does anybody have that Stylo streamable?
Ry, are you watching right now? Do you have that Stylo streamable?
I actually think this is really important right now. >> You
said he blocks everyone during the >> It's true. Okay.
I have pursued peace in the past. >> I am starting to question
whether that route is possible. So, like this idea that Nick
is spreading this narrative. He's trying to run with the narrative
that Chut is acting like a tough guy to the chat or something.
That's just never ever been true. That's not the chat's perception.
That's not anyone's perception. The perception of Chud is he
was sweeping for you being a disingenuous lying piggy. Okay?
That's what that's what Chud was doing. That's Chud's chat perception
of Chud and your relationship. Is he sweeps for you, you don't
do for him beyond, I guess, building his channel back in the
day >> in the future. Okay.
But yes, obviously things have been tense between me and Big
Nick over the past few months in no small part to you and your
gaggle of
trying to at every opportunity. >> Yeah, that's my right.
>> What does Wait a second. What does FFW stand for? Sty
>> fat boy. >> So, it's literally Chud saying that
I disagree with you guys even now.
>> Right.
By the way, Chud's very scared. I don't know if you can tell,
Chud's very scared of blacks in general. So this entire conversation
there's a whole halo of that hanging over it. Okay. A whole p
of like there's a dangerous violent criminal in my in my VC right
now. >> Obviously things have been tense. Okay. Me and
Nicholas have not been talking much recently and yes there was
a message about some recent events that have occurred and it
was kind of left at that really. Okay. But then after I made
some comments on stream yesterday in regards to the sweeping,
I believe Big Nick made a couple of comments in Discord and following
the stream, we did have a backwards and forwards about this >> Okay.
So, I don't know. I just If you think that's Chud representing
to everybody that he's actually going super hard on Nick and
I Oh, you guys are going to all be disappointed. Chud Chud acts
like a big man in private or in public, but in private he's nice
to me. No, literally everybody's like, "Why are you nice to this
guy in private? Why are you Why are you trying to have peace
with this guy?" So's like, "Yeah, I shouldn't try to have peace.
I'm just too nice." Gay.
So I It's just pretty obvious that's a lie. >> He's totally
guys. He doesn't want to deal with this at all. Then the video
from DK comes out. >> But like Conn has shaved his treat
like a big joke. You look like a total freak. You're a total
freak shaving your head for cash and you're trying to act like
it's normal. No, it's not normal. Unless you're willing to do
the 20th stream sucking off Ethan Klein. Yes, I'm talking about
you, Nicholas Dioro. Okay, dude. I saw a some stardust clip,
right? And Frogan, the stupid fat wench. I don't [__]
like Frogan, right? But she said something about the ADL
So, he puts out the segment, does the I'm calling you out, Nick
Dioro bit. So, at this point, I'm really confused cuz this makes
no [__] sense to me that he would say this and then
upload the segment. So I go, hm. Call me crazy, but I think it's
probably not you being frustrated that people keep talking about
it or trying to get us to fight each other considering that you're
now playing into it. I again I think this is >> Okay, so
later that day after after Chud talks to him, Nicholas is again
bringing it up himself
to cry about the same
You upload now you uploaded a segment on it. So he he literally
sent it twice. sent the same segment twice.
Are we are we starting to see why this guy is totally bullish?
>> Entirely reasonable position for me to have based off
the positions that Chudlock Chudlo Logic has shared. This is
not Oh no, you're messing up my money. Oh no, you're attacking
me over Ethan Klein. It's you're kind of a [__] hypocrite,
dude. This kind of sucks. So then I start responding to him.
This is hours later after the video comes out. And I go, right?
And so he goes, all the comments, not all the comments were about
you. He's been doing this for quite a while. He's extremely vague
on purpose so he can satiate his audience but also take no accountability
from me. Um, also not all the comments were I I don't think he
was trying to dodge accountability. He pretty clearly said that
you suck Ethan Klein's I don't think on that one he can dodge
accountability, right? He's saying, "Oh, other comments weren't
about you." But this one was obviously.
That would be quite the trick for Chud Logic to go uh you know
it's really dry out here. Unless you're willing to suck suck
shekels out of ETHAN KLEIN'S YES, NICHOLAS, I'M TALKING TO YOU.
ACTUALLY, NICHOLAS, that that could have been about anybody.
That could have been about any Nicholas. That could have been
about any Nicholas on the entire internet about you. It was about
everyone in sort of an amorphous blob, right? But that just means
they're going to assume it's all about me because you opened
with yes, I'm calling you out, Nick Dioro, and then you said
that later. It's annoying that when I get stupid comments about
EHD is too boring. I, and my chat can attest to this, send them
to Chudlogic and say, "Hey man, look, if you don't like what
I'm covering, you can go check out what Chud's doing. He's covering
all this different stuff." And that's totally cool. I have no
problem with that if you're kind of bored over here. So, the
difference here is if you aren't following along, if you don't
remember the previous DMs, the difference here would be Chud
has already specified he has some criticisms for the way Nick
has covered the H3 stuff. Nick watches every Chud stream. He
sends people to Chud stream. He's a huge Chud fan, right?
Nick doesn't have criticisms of Chud's coverage of anything.
Nick's never expressed that at any point here ever.
So, so Chud says, "I have like some actual principal disagreements
with you." Right?
Nick doesn't have the same thing. That's not going on over there.
That is why there's like a massive difference between like he's
like oh well I would never do this to you. It's like yeah but
I haven't given you the reason to. Right. This is one of those
things where if you're doing something wrong and you expect other
people to show loyalty to you over calling out like especially
when it's their job to call out like moral failings and stuff.
You expect them to show loyalty to you instead of calling you
out.
That's weird. You're putting them in a bad position. That's not
something a friend does, right?
You don't you don't default your friends to a position where
they have to sweep for you. That's bad. That's a bad thing to
do. That's bad. Okay, that's obviously bad.
But when Chudlo Logic has people go, hm, can you cover the new
Idubbbz thing? He just calls me a compromised sucker and attacks
my character. So, I don't know why he does that, but whatever.
Cool. Fine. But why is it >> I do think this is one of
those things where it's like a like criticism and joke at the
same time. I don't I don't truly I actually don't believe Chud
thought Nicholas was like compromised at this point. Like a totally
compromised person. It's like hey you have a bias here and it's
probably affecting your coverage. That's way different than oh
you're totally disingenuously like lying about this to make money.
Right. And
on top of this, okay,
I I can't remember where we were in May. I can't quite remember,
but around this time, weren't there people looking for a conversation
with Nick on this topic?
Wasn't Nick like actively dodging criticism on this topic already?
Maybe I'm messing up the timeline. That's why I want to do the
timeline after this. But I do believe Nick may have already been
dodging criticism on the topic.
my fault that people want you to watch the most popular topic
at the time. This just kind of sucks. I don't know. It's kind
of Chud should have had a combo with Nick over H3.
I think Chud didn't want to do that because Chud I think there's
probably some combination of things. Chud didn't have the time
to watch Nick's coverage. Chud was friends with Nick, so he wasn't
like incentivized to go deep and figure out all the things Nick
had done wrong. like other people who weren't like who who were
seeing this pattern play out because they watch everything on
the internet cuz they're creepy obsessed losers. Okay, so Chud
didn't have the time to do it. He wasn't going to invest the
time and so he didn't want to have that conversation. I think
Chud and Auggie and a couple other people were all like, "Hey,
there are criticisms of this stuff.
Would you have a conversation about it with somebody who can
verbalize those criticisms?"
And Nick refused over and over again. So Nick is actively dodging
criticism. Nick is aware there's criticism on the topic, right?
And he's actively dodging that criticism. And then he's going
to go he's going to gloss over the fact that Chud is describing
that exact criticism. He's basically saying, "Yeah, I've got
some problems." Like I don't I don't watch a lot, but I've got
some problems and I want to differentiate myself, but it puts
me in a weird position because then people like say we're going
to
All the things are here for Nicholas to to pick one of two options,
right? Either either you could say I well maybe not even one
of two but you could say something like well if you think if
you think that then criticize me directly publicly right or we
could have a conversation about it publicly or like I'm going
to I don't know like burn the bridge here and we're not friends
anymore like you you shouldn't an option shouldn't be your friend
describes some problems to you and you say okay just hold on
to those problems cuz I don't really care. Yeah, I'm never going
to address those problems. Yeah, I don't really care. Or maybe
he does say that. Okay. Kind of a weird thing to say. So then
Chud logic starts going in my opinion kind of postal. Yeah. Obviously
I have some disagreements with the way things have been discussed
recently. It's awkward because there's this pressure to have
this big blowout drama disagreement which I don't really see
the value in.
That's like that's
he doesn't see the value in it cuz he doesn't want to have a
fight with Nicholas. It's like not something that is massive
and and like has to be career ending or something at this point.
It's like, hey, I don't really have these criticisms. I don't
want to make them. This is this happens with everybody, okay?
People get a little biased. Nick's his friend. That's what's
going on here, right? It's very easy to describe. Everybody can
get this kind of bias going.
Everybody
Nick's Nick is his friends is his friend. He doesn't want to
go after him because he just does it like
basically Chud has a business here, right? And this is tough
for some people to understand. Chud is running a business and
for him there there literally isn't value, right? He has a lot
of overlap with Nick as much as everybody wants to deny that
they have a lot of overlap with each other. And what is he going
to do? Spend all of his time trying to figure out the exact right
way to criticize Nick so that he can like drag down both of them?
It's like, no, why don't you have the conversation with somebody
else? You basically admit any wrongdoing you've done and then
we all move forward.
Wouldn't that just be the easiest way to do that?
>> Whatever. It's almost like I had a completely different
understanding of who Chud Logic was in comparison to the average
viewer who consumes his live stream.
I was blown away when I watched some of the things that he would
say on stream because these are the things that he would say
to me.
So he said it's awkward because there's pressure to have this
big blowout drama disagreement which I don't see the value in
and obviously people are sniffing around for any sort of disagreement
to capitalize on for their own content and him had their little
falling out. Chud reached out and asked me and Auggie to do commentary
collabs with him.
That's like another that's like another thing. So he the reason
why you constantly keep seeing Chudlo Logic say things like,
"I appreciate what you've done for me is because he's making
reference to that. That's what he's making reference to. Uh I
don't think you've really seen my positions outside of clips
that people who are farming have sent you, but I would walk that
back if you've really watched me." And then Chudlogic says, "Obviously
I appreciate that. I appreciate what you have done for me, and
I consider you a friend. We have had disagreements and hashed
them out before, and it's fine. I mean, I was talking a bit of
[__] and I haven't even seen all your coverage, but
you're extremely favorable to Ethan to a fault. No. So, at this
>> Okay, he hasn't seen all of your
>> At this moment, I realize, oh, [__] This
guy just doesn't watch me. This guy doesn't watch anything.
>> Wait, what?
I don't know if that's true. I How could you? I don't watch all
of your coverage, but you are extremely favorable to Ethan to
a fault. know
that this guy just doesn't watch me. Wait, what part of that
statement makes you go? This guy just doesn't watch me at all.
I What can we read? Are we capable of
Hello.
What's going on here? I feel like we're losing our capability,
our ability to read.
Also, that title in the thumbnail is very tame. No one is getting
called a pedto. Okay. >> Thing that I had a Dude, this
guy literally does not watch my content. Uh, and you don't have
to to be my friend. You don't have to watch my streams or watch
my videos. Now, I was very active in his chat and I was I enjoyed
his show a lot and I thought he was a really respectable guy.
But at this point, I realized, oh, he just doesn't watch my show,
right?
Why didn't you just say Wait, what what did he say that was wrong
there?
Just the two a fault part.
Just is it just the two of fault part? Because I don't think
Nicholas could possibly deny that his coverage is extremely favorable
to Ethan Klein. I don't think he would deny that. He would say
that that's just the correct thing. If if the read he has the
read, the read is correct. You should be favorable to Ethan Klein.
I I don't know. Oh, this guy this guy thinks I'm favorable to
Ethan Klein. He just doesn't watch my coverage.
cue his reply to the aristocracy tweet about they sent they sent
two skulls because he has two children. Oh my god. Oh my god.
It's the number of skills matches the number of skulls matches
the number of children
like dude. Uh
it's
like he's part he's got like contact
JN. Okay. >> So then he goes also that title and thumbnail
is very tame. No one's getting called the pedto. So I guess at
this point I got off better than Lix. Lix
Lix got it worse than me.
So this one is basically inconsequential. This is me trying Did
Chud state some Did Chud state some disagreements here or is
Nick just going to start saying all the criticisms he's seen
he's seen on Twitter and block people over?
Wait, how does this work?
Do you see how it works forward in the >> 536 to 540. I
agree with you on NX.
I support that.
Does he just start listing off all of the things it could be?
So, this one is basically inconsequential. This is me trying
to just establish talking points to see what the problem is.
I'll go through it just for the sake of showing all the DMs,
but it's not really relevant. I agree with you on Nux. I support
the no legal threat on the basis that he has defamed people maliciously
in the past, Chudlogic. But I've also said that Ethan should
probably leave it at a threat, and I'd be open to seeing >> defamed
people maliciously in the past, Chudlo Logic. Did Chud def defame
somebody maliciously? >> It gets filed if ever it didn't.
And reassessing I think the Nazi sword was on purpose, but it
was
hold on. You understand that being an extremely rich person and
threatening litigation and sending cease and desist. This is
all that's like wild. Both Mudahar and Ethan did this to to silence
criticism specifically.
You should be against that you
>> dude. It's actually crazy. >> Safe edgy not their
secret KKK attackers. It was done for Safe Edgy owns. Uh when
they correct him that it's Amongi. In regards to the ban, this
is a random Hassan [__] ban from 6 months ago. Not
really relevant here. Um I said that he probably shouldn't be
banned otherwise. I literally don't know what other topics we
even disagree on. So that was me kind of uh just establishing
talking points, but we rip it back. We go back to the actual
discussion. So then he goes, "Also, the title and thumbnail is
very tame and no one's getting called a pedto." So I then rip
the conversation back to the topic at hand and say, "The confusion
is you seem frustrated about the drama baiting and this seems
like another escalation that will extend it." Which I think again
warranted question. Chudlogic says, "Oh, okay. I mean, I said
to DK to take it easy on the title and thumbnail, mainly because
I'm probably going to lose subs over. Remember when Chudlo Logic
went live yesterday and said, "GUYS, I LOSE SUBS ALL THE TIME.
NONE OF THIS MATTERS TO ME." WELL, AGAIN, in private, he actually
is worried about losing those subscribers. That was something
that mattered to him. Now, as time progressed, I started to realize
that Chudlo Logic probably didn't even like me. He was just probably
worried that I was going to pull out and take the rest of my
viewers with me, which is what happened. That is what I did.
So, that he just lied about
>> Oh, really? I think he was I think he spent a lot of
capital with his own audience defending you. Like I I think a
lot of people in his own audience were pretty upset with him
for defending Nick to be honest.
Also, Nick pulled out with his own viewers. Ch's getting what?
1,000 on
a thousand on YouTube and
300 on kick.
Is that not I feel like that's
I feel like that's pretty much where he was. Was he like maybe
when he was doing the like Turkey Tom interview type content
maybe he was bigger but like since May or something it's that's
been where he was. I don't know >> that as well. But yeah,
I mean there isn't much going on worthy of a segment. So I'm
just trying to carve something
What the does that mean? Wait.
So wait, you're telling me you Sean? You're telling me that you
were bored on a random [__] like Tuesday afternoon
and you just snaked me and you just told me in plain English
that that's what you did. I didn't have any content so I just
um difference is this uh is this the difference? Um
hold on. The difference says the difference is obviously Chud
losing subs because of his takes versus DK thumbnails and stuff.
Well, I think
I think he realizes that him and Nicholas have overlap and he's
like, I don't want to go after Nicholas like that hard because
it will up like the
Maybe maybe he should have said like maybe this is like a weird
read for somebody else where where he's saying like, you know,
mainly because I probably this might be like something that's
weird to say to your friend, right? Sure.
I think Chud at this point still feels like it's a joke and doesn't
feel like it's super substantial and doesn't think like Nicholas
should be that offended by
is probably like he's probably still not quite reading in how
upset Nick is about this is like my read when he says that >> just
called you a [__] >> that's too charitable.
>> How the [__] was I supposed to interpret
this? I'm just curious how the [__] was I supposed
to interpret this message where he's like, "Yeah, dude. I was
for content that day." So, I just snaked
Then he goes, "Just unfortunate that it's the most interesting
thing that happened on my stream yesterday." So, apparently when
Chud snakes you, if his content sucks for the day, he just doubles
down.
And Chud, by the way, he'll tell you he's got no idea why I'm
upset about this. He'll tell you that it's irrational to be angry
that Chud logic in plain English told me he me
I think he just
it's just so vague I don't really know what to say. I
I see this as Chud thinking like he did a joke and Nick is like
kind of annoyed about it but not that annoyed about it.
I Right.
Is that not like what's going on here?
So Nick stands on the that H3 coverage. I guess so. I I guess
so. >> I mean, that is just outrageous.
>> That's not what he's saying. I mean, he's I think he
already said he didn't want to fight with a guy and he's just
like, "Oh, you know, I told I told DK to take it easy because
we're going to lose subs over like Milani Nicholas."
I could see how if you like thought you were very close friends,
that might seem weird that that's his primary concern. I
I I could see it. I could see it.
I'm trying to go back to
95 two minutes.
Confusion is that you seem frustrated about the drama baiting
and this is seems like another escalation that will extend it.
Uh I think he's upset about his audience drama baiting. I don't
think he's like I think he's fine with throwing those little
like quips out there.
And Chud, by the way, he'll tell you he's got no idea why I'm
upset about that. Is just outrageous, isn't it? But I have not
put that out wanting to promote provoke more drama intentionally,
even though it will have that effect.
But I have not put that out wanting to provoke more drama intentionally,
even though it will have that effect. Okay.
I
there's just again those two things like
like he's balancing two different concerns. He's balancing trying
to be honest with trying to maintain his friendship with Nicholas.
And I'm going to keep saying that I think it's Nicholas who's
putting everybody else in a position where they have to pretend
that this isn't like totally disingenuous. where they have to
pretend over and over again everybody has to do this this weird
thing where they pretend that Nicholas's coverage isn't disingenuous.
It isn't weird. It's not like over the top. It's not way too
favorable. It's not borderline lying in some cases. Okay. It's
not like a total backtracking on several stated principles.
We have we just have to keep pretending all of these different
things for Nicholas's benefit.
And if Nicholas were a friend, I think he would step forward
when Chud says, "I'm concerned about this." and ask and and like
uh not just not just litigate those things privately. Do you
know what I
It's like debate me privately. Debate me privately on me being
disingenuous.
No, you you can't mention it publicly until you've debated me
privately.
I Is he not just He's inverting the debate thing. You have to
debate me privately before you discuss this publicly. Come on,
man. We're friends. I think maybe just
probably just don't engage in months and months of conduct that
your friends might find like uh criticism with probably. Oh,
okay. Yeah. I mean, that's a that's a pretty heavy line, Chud.
Then I said, I'm going to ignore the people telling me to respond
to you. Half because I really didn't see any reason to make this
a huge thing, and half because it's so vague. I really don't
know what to say. Anything I'll do will sound after a three-hour
creator clash segment. And you might remember this message.
This is the message that he didn't want to show. I guess this
is the one.
Where is it?
This is the one he didn't want to show. Uh yeah, man. If you
want to hop in a call off stream and really hash some of this
out, we can. It's up to you. I think that we have more disagreements
than what you're saying. Maybe just having a frank convo makes
things easier. But I am not looking to fall out over this, even
though there are many people that want me to. I'm ready for
now. I'm just curious.
I That's
this I didn't see this one before. This is totally criticizable.
I think this is more avoidant.
And hey, everybody does this to some extent. This is sort of
what social norms are built on, right? You sort of you don't
say your criticism as bluntly as possible because you do want
to maintain relationships. So, it's not like I'm totally overcritical,
but he's like feeling just feeling a bit ripped for content.
No, you're feeling annoyed with your friend that he keeps putting
you like he doesn't care that he's putting you and your audience
at odds at all. He doesn't give a and he expects you to keep
sweeping for him with like with no complaints.
That's That's what you're actually annoyed about. And you don't
want to say that cuz you don't want to burn that
Ah, too bad. Too bad. didn't go on and make a >> I don't
I don't really believe this. Oh, I'm just feeling a little rich
for content. I don't I don't really believe this, but he said
it public tate out of this. I didn't drop this guy in May. I
gave this guy an opportunity to talk to me. He ghosted me for
3 months and this guy wrote me in DMs telling me that he felt
rap for content. So, he me
I think that's kind of crazy. I think that's a crazy thing to
write somebody. And I think the issue here is if there is some
misinterpretation that I'm not
that still also falls on him. The reason we're talking about
this is because he started leaking. The reason that I'm even
bringing this up now is cuz he started leaking
to be clear. He he posted the messages, right? But I re I I think
this was all I I don't get like a different feel from any of
this other than I do blame Chud, but I think Chud said this for
not reaching back out to Nicholas. I do think like Chud had every
reason to expect from this point on that Nicholas was going to
be like Frosty to him. Like after after they have this conversation
and he's like, "Hey, we could have a conversation after this."
And I think there's even messages under this that like Nick is
saying like we should talk at some point soon. I think Chud not
following up on that is pretty bad, right? Just in terms of maintaining
a friendship. >> Reached out to him and I wanted to have
a call about it. >> Yeah. So, two days two days later he
says, "Hey, be down to have a call about it sometimes this week."
Sometime this week. Now, this happens as well with friends. Okay.
They sort of like fall out of talking and to clarify what he
said back in May and he ignored me. So if there is some weird
>> back in May like two days before >> and he ignored
me. >> So if there is some weird >> angle to these
messages that I can't possibly deduce, >> he just chose
not to talk about it.
And I'm the coward, by the way. I'm the coward for this. I'm
the coward.
So here are some examples. Hey uh hey dude. It's been a minute.
I hope you're doing well. Uh me asking if the video is fake.
Yo. And then back to where we are now, right? So, this is back
in November. Uh, the last message that we had was like midepptember,
I think. All right. So, that's kind of the stuff that Chud chose.
>> Oh, there is also a thing here where if they just pick
up after a couple days, they just pick up talking as normal.
I think if they just pick up talking as normal and they do have
normal conversations through like June, July, August, then it
does look like Nicholas wasn't actually that bothered or
Nick, I've got more stuff and this this message will still remain
relevant as we move forward, but I want to establish a timeline
with you because some people don't understand. Okay, Nick Chud
over in May of last year and you were lied about it. You didn't.
>> So, this is where, by the way, this is like where he's
sneaking something in. Chud Chud totally you over by saying,
you suck shekels or what did he say? If you unless you're willing
to suck Ethan Klein's or something. He said you're a sucker for
Ethan Klein. Okay. Right.
Is that is that really totally Nicholas over?
Is that what that is?
I There's a couple ways you could look at that. Okay. If you
see each other as
then that could be banter between friends. If you see yourself
as better than somebody,
then you might look at that as them trying to peel people like
off of your audience over time,
There's like you can have banter between
that exists, but I think if you if you if you've consistently
seen yourself as above somebody the entire time you've been like
quote unquote friends, I do think there's something there where
you're like, "Well, wait, what? Why would you say that? Don't
you understand that I help you? Don't you understand that I bless
you with my presence? Do you not understand that, Chud? Do you
not understand that I bless you with my
Um, no. Timelines are just good. Uh, temporally thinking about
stuff is really important because it it gives you like a very
good idea of what's going on all of the time.
Yeah, that's my whole point is I think Nick has just always there's
a there's a couple little comments from Nick where you just start
to build up this idea that he's always seen himself as like better
than Chud and that he was nice enough to help Chud with some
stuff and I think he feels like I helped you out so much and
you weren't even willing to you weren't even willing to help
me out. You weren't even willing to like apologize for calling
me a what the man make a huge public issue about it. Um you didn't
explode and blow him up or something back then. So why is this
a problem now? Well, eagle-eyed viewers would point out that
this message right
was on January 14th of 2026
at 2:01 p.m. where I told him, "Yeah, man. Good luck with whatever
you're doing over here. So, there's no nuclear holocaust coming.
Nick's not going to go on a pirate and attack you. There's no
drama." A thing. They got him. We're back up.
Hello.
I I will say
um this does make everything clear to me now because I did think
like before this
and I maybe this is just maybe this is bad because I've never
called Chud out for it but I was like oh Chud Chud was willing
to like hop on this really early. I wonder just how bad the the
situation with like Nick and stuff is. Like I wonder just how
bad it is actually.
And it it turns out that right before this they basically said
we're going our separate ways and so he's like oh I don't have
to I don't have to sweep for these people at all anymore. I can
just you know speak freely and be a drama guy.
Like I that was my impression when I saw Chud going like so in
so hard on the Turkey Tom stuff early. I'm like oh he must not
really be friends with those guys anymore. He's not like willing
to wait and and see if he could get like some behind the scenes
info. He's just going hard with this the second it comes out.
I I inferred that the relationship was over. I'm recording this
in full, so the version that you'll get is fine. >> Kind
of interesting.
>> We're back. Okay, I'll just So, this is January 14th,
2026 at 2:01 p.m. And at this point, yeah, man, good luck with
whatever you're doing. I'm fine with just leaving it there. I
think that this guy me over in May. I'm not making it a public
issue. I don't really care. It's fine. We can move on. I think
what he said on stream was kind of whack, but fine. Let's move
on from there. All right. I'm getting told that uh Becket might
have had some opinions on this and that Nick might have been
in Beckett's chat talking about it. We'll see. We'll see. We'll
see. Then a couple hours later, my friend gets accused of domestic
violence, assault, uh down the line, like all these things, like
all these things, right? And at 8 a.m. the next morning, the
great sweep was on.
Yes. Yes. That is the timeline here. I said, "Hey, man. I'm ready
to move on. we could just go on with our lives.
>> Oh, this is another big reach from Nicholas that I don't
think is clear. And I think I think it's obviously clear
because of the rest of the content Chuck did on this. >> Logic
finds out my friend got accused of rape and then snakes me at
8:00 the next morning. My concern, ladies and gentlemen, is the
>> Well, we knew we knew about all of this, yes, in the
background, but like the explicit, oh, we're done with each other
messages didn't happen until right before the Turkey Tom stuff,
which is pretty funny. >> Big sweep might be on. Okay.
The mid the big sweep might >> So, this guy stuck a dagger
right into my neck the minute we stopped talking.
>> I just I think
Okay, he's saying May here. I I think he is like like talking
I don't think he's saying Nicholas is sweeping this. He's like
hinting at something that he's predicting that he thinks, "Oh,
I don't think you guys are going to cover this. I think you guys
are going to ignore this." Right?
You can tell he's hedging. He's like, "I think you guys will
ignore
Okay. Literally, the minute now,
again, there's two ways to look at this, right? You'll ignore
this. It's not ignoring it because you will ignore it if it's
like proven out or something. It's like ignoring it because you
guys would normally cover like partial accusations. You'd cover
like reviews, things that are gray areas, but with your friends,
you're not going to cover the gray area because it includes like
embarrassing material, right? That was I think that's Chud's
core thesis is not that you would necessarily like cover up this
guy people, but that you would like wait to cover it until you
could see if there was a way you could angle a
Now, Chud ended up being wrong on that, but I do wonder if he'd
never commented if anybody would have done anything there, right?
I think Chud's Chud's comments pushed these people to cover it
in a way that I I wouldn't have really expected it. And I I disagreed
with Chud, by the way, that they even had to. I I personally
disagreed that Nicholas had to. I said, "Hey, if that's your
friend, you could just say, "I'm too close to that. I'm not going
to give you my opinion. My opinion will be too biased." I think
you'd easily do that. I understand people say, "Oh, well, you
know, they they cover everybody else to the people who say you
have to hold your friends accountable."
I don't I don't think it's the same with Tom.
You know what I'm saying?
I also wonder what the response would have been if they'd never
figured out or never been told by Tom like, "I got this." Like,
"Don't worry, I got this 100%. I got it." Right? If they like,
let's say Tom goes dark. H Tom Dark. What happens then?
Right. Stating your biases would be enough. Yeah, just say I'm
biased and I don't want to cover this. I think that's totally
fine. Personally,
uh I did that with when the Destiny DMs dropped with Lauren Southern.
There's just like personal and DMs. No, none of the nudes had
dropped yet. I declined to cover it. I was like, "This person
has done a lot for me. I feel it's rude of me like it would be
disingenuous of me to go and and cover these like just personally
humiliating messages
if um like when there's nothing tangible there. There's not really
like I didn't think there's anything tangible there is my personal
opinion, right? It's just embarrassing. Well, I don't have to
go cover those. I don't have any problem with that. So, but again,
I don't think um I don't think Chud's saying you're definitely
sweeping. You're 100% sweeping here. >> Can't we stop talking
like Oh, dude. It's just it's just the the big sweep. Why are
you mad about being called the sweeper? My friend's getting accused
of beating women. You son of a [__]
I That's not an argument.
>> Sweep my >> So, this guy stuck a dagger right
into my neck the minute we stopped talking. Literally the minute
we stopped talking. I'm like, "Oh, dude, it's just it's just
the the big sweep. Why are you bad about being called the sweeper?
My friends >> the big sweep might be in." What? What was
he saying here about this when it was happening?
I just I do wonder like do we have to go back and watch this
whole thing? Like was he trying to because I do think this is
talking about Nicholas. He's probably just referring to this
Nicholas thing. But do we have to go back and watch this? Cuz
again, he's just saying like I think the big sweep might be in.
He changed the cartoon image of Dior. No, it's Dude, it's fine.
>> He's getting accused of beating women. Son of a [__]
[laughter] You son of a [__] Dude, the implication
that I would just ignore my friend doing domestic violence is
like character assassination.
That's like Yeah, it's insane, dude. Of course. Of course I'd
be about it.
It's
again, there's like memes here. There's a bunch of like this,
right?
Dioro expected Chud to be his house ninja. Yeah, I think so.
So, okay, we're continue to watch this.
I don't see that as like a I see that as like a you don't see
that as an attack on your credibility. You know what I mean?
He's like postulating, but I don't see that as like a a major
attack on your credibility. He's saying I'll have to hold off
and see what happens. Right? That's why he's saying maybe.
I think it's a it's like a you and that makes way more sense
now that I know that you guys just broke up like the day
But again, I don't think it's I don't think it's like a um a
straightup shot. But we'll have to see. I don't know what Chud
also said this night this evening. Like he might have said way
more. So we'll have to see what else in this video might be.
>> I don't think I' seen past this point. >> The
mid the big sweep might >> keep watching. >> We'll
keep watching. On top of that, Chud has to know that I was live
while the allegations were dropping. Meaning that I was in front
of an audience doing a show. It is impossible that I was dual
wielding a live Kiwi Farms thread to know anything about this
when at the end of my stream I announced the podcast was on hiatus
cuz we had an episode dropping the next day.
But he tries to use that to implicate Tom as guilty.
>> I am not participating in the big sweep. >> Sorry.
He's um No, no, no, no. You just said he doesn't watch you. He's
literally watching clips from like some the Google doc that got
prepared for him on the uh like from the Kiwi Farms thread that
includes Nick right here on his stream talking about it live.
>> He is aware. >> At the end of my stream, I announced
the podcast was on hiatus because we had an episode dropping
the next day.
>> But he tries to use that to implicate Tom as guilty.
>> No, he doesn't. >> I am not participating in the
big sweep. Okay. This is a totally legitimate story to cover
and talk about. And that's the end of it, bro. And if anyone
disagrees, if anyone thinks I'm doing something wrong, we'll
talk about. >> So, on that part right there, that's Chud
responding to people in his chat who are calling it a nothing
burger. That one is obviously not about Nicholas, right?
But the whole thing where where Nicholas is trying to say that
this is proof that Turkey Tom is guilty. Now, I said
I said personally,
this looks really weird. I don't know why you would do this.
Like this looked weird to me that you immediately go on hiatus
without even without even identifying like what's in the thread.
You say you're going on hiatus. That to me sounds like you've
talked to Tom and Tom has like
like you basically didn't like the answers you were getting somehow.
Like you might have known this was coming out for a while and
you were already prepared for this. That's what that sounds like.
Like you haven't looked at the allegations at all and you're
going on a hiatus. That does seem weird. It doesn't make Tom
guilty. It's just super weird. by the way also makes a ton of
people on the internet kind of think you're like making him look
guilt like you are basically casting him aside
and I do believe there are more comments from Nicholas on this
hiatus that look worse
right
like I think on his next stream he talks about how there about
the podcast and says like yeah it is definitely on hiatus we're
definitely not doing it for a while or something or he does a
tweet there's something about this where they actually like do
official posts and put it on hiatus and I'm like now you've talked
to Tom or now you've like looked at the evidence You can see
that like it's thin. There's not a lot of real evidence there.
And you're putting everything on hiatus before you've talked
to him or or you've talked to him and you're still putting it
on hiatus. One of the two. I don't like it looks bad, man. It
just looks bad anyway you slice it.
>> Do people hate Tom again? >> About it. Okay. Happy
to talk about it.
dude. But there is literally nothing wrong with speaking about
this and talking about this.
This is >> Stephen Jellian. I don't think you meet the
IQ requirements for this chat. You might want to find one that's
a little more your speed. >> It's completely legitimate.
And >> so right here, >> IQ requirement is 75. By
the way, >> he brings up another interesting point.
>> Nicholas Jory on Twitter. Nick just responded. Oh, just
to be clear, I've seen literally >> Is there anybody on
planet Earth who wouldn't feel backstabbed by this? nothing of
what's occurred tonight, but my understanding is that Halfbaked
is on haters for a little while. So, we'll see in the next couple
of days where that goes. Okay. And then there's a clip there.
Nick,
>> I think you should go to like another chat and complain
about this stream in another chat like you've been doing. I think
you should do that. >> States the halfbaked. His podcast
with Tom and Lord Vega is going on haters for a while. Video
could be DMs. Here's the thing with this, okay? Anyone that wants
to claim that this is a nothing burger,
Why the
is the podcast going on hiatus, >> So, my friend Tom is
guilty because the guy who was live when the allegations dropped
wasn't comfortable with releasing a video until he knew it was
happening. This is like not rocket science here. So, he's trying
to say that because I put the podcast on hiatus. Don't reach
out and ask about it for something this serious. By the way,
that let's just from the hip.
No. What happening? This is like not rocket science. Oh, sorry.
I on haters for a little while. So, we'll see in the next couple
of days where that goes. Okay. And then there's a clip there.
Nick Duro states the halfbaked his podcast with Tom and Lord
Vega is going on haters for a while. Video's
thing with this. Okay. Anyone that wants to claim that this is
a nothing burger.
Why the [__] is the podcast going on hiatus, dude?
>> So, my friend Tom is
Yeah. No, this is a totally reasonable read. By the way, this
does not make Tom guilty. It just means that it's something serious,
something that actually needs to be taken seriously. This doesn't
mean guilty.
But this is everyone's read. You are a complete if you don't
understand this is everybody's
that you made Tom look more guilty that people could have just
totally dismissed this as like there's not really a lot of tangible
evidence there. It's pretty weird until null came in and like
verified identities. It's like there's there's really not a lot
of tangible evidence there. Uh we'll we'll like see what happens.
And then Nick comes in and goes, "Yeah, everything's on hiatus
right now."
Right? That's that's not him saying it's guilty. That's the obvious
common sense read when you on the night that this all drops go,
"Obviously, guys, halfbaked on hiatus for a while. It sounds
like you've heard about it. It sounds like you understand it's
serious,
right?
And again, shut is fighting with the people who are saying it's
a nothing in the chat. Anyway, we >> because the guy who
was live when the allegations dropped wasn't comfortable with
releasing a video until he knew it was happening. This is like
not rocket science here. So, he's trying to say because I put
the podcast on hiatus. Don't reach out and ask about it for something
this serious. By the way, that [__] Let's just from
the hip.
That makes zeroing
sense, bro. that >> why why would he have to reach out
about
>> That it it looks weird. You've made it look weird to
everybody. >> That makes zero sense. Okay.
If this is nothing to worry about, nothing to be concerned about.
Okay. Why is the >> He's twisting my statement to say my
friend is guilty. >> Podcast going on hatus. Okay. Now
>> No, your statement implies that it's serious.
If it was nothing, you wouldn't be putting the podcast on hiatus.
It might mean you need to like you know that this person's real
that that like this is something that you have to look into.
It could just mean that Chud's not saying anything else, right?
He's just saying it looks more serious. It looks like it's not
a nothing burger cuz they literally canled the they they're putting
their podcast on hiatus because of this.
So if you're saying it's a nothing burger, you sound kind of
dumb.
That's not saying guilt. Why Why is he just making that up? >> Listen,
I will be fair. I know what people in chat are thinking and are
going to say. >> Oh, he's fair, guys. He's fair. >> Okay,
but my concern, ladies and gentlemen, is the big sweep might
be on. Okay, the >> the big sweep is you smearing [__]
all over the place. >> The big sweep might be on.
>> That doesn't make any sense. It's a totally nonsensical
statement.
I am not participating in the big sweep.
Okay, this is a totally >> Now, let's dial it back here
because eagle-eyed viewers would point out that when the time
came, Chudlo Logic did say that Nick Dioro did stream this. So,
what what you're missing here is that this whole conversation
was actually a shot at a Cheeto. Now, I know he mentions Hassan
[__] and I know he mentions E Idubbbz or whatever,
but this was actually a >> Does Nick Is is Nick pretending
he doesn't know what like Sensitive Society and more Pegasus
and these channels. More Pegasus, by the way, number one commentary
channel that these people complain about? Does he not is he pretending
that those don't exist? Hold
Does Nicholas not understand that there are a bunch of creators
that are as big or bigger than him who constantly do this stuff,
who constantly
cover just the same people over and over again? All the same
people Nicholas covers.
To be fair, Chad is talking about Nick. He's talking about it
when he mentions this big sweep being in. But the next day, right,
I think the next day when he goes live, he he makes it clear
that like now he's talking about these other
right?
But there are like Nick is somebody who is included here, but
there are other channels that do this,
right? There are obviously other things or other channels that
do this. There's this guy, there's Sensitive Society, there's
a couple other channels that do this exact line of content. This
Hassan [__] is bad content,
right? But I do I I'm not saying Nick isn't included. Nick is
I think Nick is included in this first night where he's talking
about this big sweep. So from the YouTube drama subreddit post
about the Turkey Tom allegations. Is there anyone besides Tad
who's gone over the thing in full so this is the next day
and so he he continued to complain about it and all of the people
who weren't this is obviously not complaining about him, right?
So the first comment includes Nick, but Nick is including in
his outrage all the comments after the first comment too. The
first comment is not that consequential. the big sweep might
be in. Right. That's what he's talking that's pretty obvious.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, so he's doing the collective statement that includes
Nick and then he explicitly unincludes Nick because Nick covered
it,
right?
So I would I would even argue he's probably primarily referring
to Nick
when he first makes the statement and then he retracts Nick.
He says not Nick now because Nick has covered it.
But again he's not saying there's a sweep in. He's saying the
big sweep might be in. He's like doing a
and they have changed the big sweep might be in to these guys
are sweeping.
But he wasn't saying that because obviously there was no chance
for them to even speak.
Right. There's zero there's zero opportunity for them to even
speak on it. There's no way he's saying you are sweeping. Right.
He's recconing targets. I don't think so because I do believe
that this was significantly even that morning about about more
Pegasus. I maybe I'm misremembering the timeline, but I want
to say in spicy chat that morning people were complaining about
more Pegasus sensitive society, the fact that they wouldn't actually
cover this [__] right? Am I crazy?
I I I don't even disagree, Stazzy, that uh Nick is the primary
target when he says the the sweep the big sweep might be in,
but that's that's what that morning and then this is the next
day.
No. So, so it got released the evening of the 16th, I think.
No,
no, this can't be. This has to be a day later. This has to be
like a full day later. Like Chud streamed that morning after
it dropped and then there had to have been a full day that had
gone by, right? And then this stuff drops. Like he makes this
tweet and he explicitly discludes Nick.
Yeah, I'm I'm agreeing with you guys that it's mostly about them,
but I'm telling you that like that next morning
there were people complaining about the other commentary channels.
an interesting argument that was being levied toward
um sensitive society
except there's one issue with that >> question bro okay
now I don't think listen guys okay listen okay okay
I do not believe that people have got an obligation to cover
anything people can cover what they want okay
but my question would be
what would the coverage be like if this is about Idubbbz if it
>> okay so this is the day after his first stream he says
there's nobody else who's covered it so this would be in the
afternoon and then that evening right of the 16th
then Nicholas covers it and then the day that's the next day
so this is the first morning he posts and then he says my video's
been up for 11 hours it's doing really well why is nobody else
covering this like all the daily commentary slap channels would
normally have a video out by now I think he's even jumping the
gun here he's probably too early here
Right.
Anyway, we could do >> it was revealed that Idubbbz
that that Ana was into age play and [__] like that.
What would the coverage be? And I think the answer to that tells
you everything that you need to know, doesn't it? [laughter]
>> So, catch that last part that tells you everything you
need to know. >> The Idubbbzs that that Ana was into age
play and [__] like that. What would the coverage
be? And I think the answer to that tells you everything that
you need to know. >> So he explicitly says the daily slop
channels here. Is that Do you think that is talking about Nicholas?
I am I the only one who doesn't think that that's talking about
Nicholas that he's like already walked that back a little bit
at this point.
That to me is like very clearly talking about the specific people
that are getting complained about and spicy. But maybe not, >> doesn't
it? [laughter] >> So, catch that last part. That tells
you everything you need to know. That tells you everything you
need to know. And then here, it's it's there's 20 videos from
Daily Slop channels, but listen to him here. Listen to the rest
of what he says in the actual stream where this take was originated
from. >> The answer to that tells you everything that you
need to know, doesn't it?
But nonetheless,
I'm not making any firm claims. I don't know what's going to
happen. I can't predict the future. I can't predict the future,
guys, okay?
But to me, you can look at who decides to talk about this and
who doesn't, and that will give you an indication
of what the deal is. >> Now, people were like,
>> "Yeah, I
Okay,
look, I
I think this is him trying to say you guys shouldn't shouldn't
like uh back off of covering this." I think that's what he's
saying. You guys shouldn't back off of covering this. He's trying
to push them to cover it.
I see it as it's just very obvious to >> Like Nick is speculative.
This was obviously a shot at sensitive. Then here he is in plain
English telling it's about me. It's about me. It was about me.
He literally told me in plain English it was. Do you think I
lied to?
>> So again, he's he's conflating. This is the first stream
and the tweet about the commentary slot people is hours after
that. Like maybe even a full day after that, right? So on this
stream, I have no doubt that he's talking about Nick. I'm fully
behind the idea that he's talking about Nick.
Fully behind it.
I don't know if that's the case when it goes to the tweet. Now,
people were like, "Nick is speculatory. This was obviously a
shot at sensitive." Then here he is in plain English telling
it's about me. It's about me. It was about me. He literally told
me. >> But I will say I was expecting you not to cover
this. So there is that. Yeah, I I guess I hadn't seen this part
yet, but hey, there it is right there. Plain
>> in plain English it was. Do you think I lied to you?
Do you think I make up? So, my comment about who will cover this
and who won't is a jab at you to be transparent. It's [__]
He told me he told me it was about me.
You think I [__] made this up, bro? I had endless
charitability for this guy. I waited so [__] I so
when he's speaking conditionally the big sweep might be in.
We pay attention to who will cover this and who won't. He was
he was like [__] he's saying you to Nicholas right
he was doing that
but it's not him saying you're sweeping cuz that wouldn't make
any sense.
I don't think I'm I don't think I'm being crazy on this >> [__]
long to expose this guy, bro.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I HAVE PUT UP WITH WITH THIS GUY?
I don't want to leak the DMs. MY WORD IS MY NO, YOU DON'T WANT
TO LEAK THE DMs cuz you look like an
I'm getting a bunch of commentary trulians coming in saying nothing,
burger. No big deal. I'm saying if it's no big deal, why is the
podcast on hold now? It's a precaution so you can assess which
is reasonable. So I agree it's aggressive to put it the damage
is done, you [__] Of of course I'm mad about this.
Basically, not everything I say about you is about you and but
I was expecting you not to cover this at all to be totally upfront.
We'll get to this. I'm going to show you the rest of this. It's
not super relevant, but again, if I don't release it, he will.
So let's just go through it. So, my comment about who will cover
this and who won't is a
>> Oh, dude, Chud's saying the exact same thing I am. Yeah.
So, when he says if you're going to argue it's a nothing burger,
look at the fact that they they paused their podcast, that means
it's something substantial. >> Yeah. But you to be transparent.
So, that's what he said. Cool.
So, just to be clear, then he got the video out on January 15th.
So, that's the same is it same day? Yeah, same like afternoon
of the same day. And then he ran to his little Discord server
and said he's sick of the big sweep and fired off the uh he got
all he got his entire army in here. How is it that my video has
the most views of this topic? It's insane. I don't know, dude.
Maybe it's because your video came out the same day that you
streamed about it at 8:00 in the morning after the allegations
dropped and we're dropping all night long the night before. Maybe
that is I don't know. Maybe that has something to do with it.
The issue is that Chud Logic might have been correct. He might
have been correct,
but you can't come out and say the big sweep is on at 8 a.m.
the next >> the big sweep might be on. I'm not saying it
is. Watch who covers it. Watch who does it?
What part of that is confusing?
What part of that is confusing? What part of that is calling
Nicholas a disingenuous who won't cover it? It's literally saying,
"I dare you not to cover it now. You thought you might get away
without covering it, but you have to cover it now.
I he is I totally agree. He's throwing a grenade at Nicholas
there. Okay, I agree. I agree.
What I don't agree on is that he was saying Nicholas is obviously
sweeping.
Yeah, it's just it's obviously not >> Next morning, while
the allegations were going all night, that's you've overshot.
You've overcommitted to your point and you look like an that's
the reality of it. But my issue isn't any of that. I don't care
if his take is bad. My issue is that he used it to jab a knife
into my back. That's why I was upset about it personally. So,
there's a few other things that I want to go through, but before
that, I'm going to be fully transparent with our DMs on Twitter.
So, yes, this is the one that you've definitely heard about.
I was fuming. I went on there. I saw the big sweep is on. I realized,
holy, this guy and me >> Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
When is this upset about it? from this on the 16th at 2 a.m.
He's in Chicago, so it to be on the 16th or the morning of the
>> 16th. Okay, I'm looking I'm trying to look through these
um >> what do you call it? Through these DMs, see what's
going on here. >> Few other things that I want to go through,
but before that, I'm going to be fully transparent with our DMs
on Twitter. So, yes, this is the one that you definitely heard
about. I was fuming. I went on there. I saw the big sweep is
on. I realized I want to go through, but before that, I'm going
to be fully transparent with our DMs on Twitter. So, yes, this
is the one that you've definitely heard about. I was fuming.
I went on there. I saw the big sweep is on. I realized, "Holy
[__] this guy and me literally had a falling out
yesterday. He's already stabbing me in the back. This is unbelievable."
So, I sent him the messages that he showed you. The uh that not
everything has to come to some catastrophic breakdown. I know
you're used to that. And I said, "Jesus, dude. Yesterday you
were saying like this to me today, and now you're thrashing me
because my friend got accused of horrific."
I'm not really sure how I was supposed to navigate this stuff
better than I did when I only just found out there were even
allegations at the tail end of my live show. And to that, Chud
said, I mean, go live and cover it. >> Whatations at the
tail end of my live show? To that Chud said, I mean, go live
and cover it. >> What? Like you would with anyone or don't
if you feel like you're too close to it. Dude, I think that you
avoid stuff that would be negative to cover. Is that unreasonable?
I go, wait, hold on. So, you're saying that you would blindfire
your friend's Kiwi Farms thread at midnight while the allegations
are still dropping?
Or am I just misunderstanding you? Like, what is the argument
here?
Or do you mean like, should I go live now? Like, what what are
we talking about here, bro? And then he goes, I mean, it just
feels like I can never be critical of you in any way without
getting a message from you. Like, you're trying to keep me on
my side. Now, he's using the the current talking points. Then
it turns out you do have this issue with me since May and you
haven't said anything to me about it. Chud, I asked to chat with
you what had happened and you never got back to me and then I
kept the line of communication open. Now eventually Chud does
finally tell the truth that this is partially his fault when
he says, "Yeah, I could have been more clear on my end, too.
I never wanted to have some big crash out falling out with you
and I wanted to try and keep things amicable or neutral because
I have no reason to dislike you and I appreciate what you've
done for
>> Why did he not release these DMs? Yeah, why do you do
it? That's a good point. Um, yeah, I saw that. That wasn't you,
bro. dude sometimes. >> So, like it seems like the biggest
complaint they have about Chud is that he said it doesn't have
to be some big crash out and then the Turkey Tom stuff drops
and he like throws um he basically throws a challenge out to
Nicholas like
I don't think you're going to cover this.
Is that snaky? Do we consider that
I is Is this all going to just come down to like people being
hurt, having their feelings hurt, and so they're throwing like
little shots at each other the whole time? Is this just all mean?
It's just mean girls all the way down. Is it I Oh,
because I I do feel like Chud, it's pretty clear Chud is throwing
like a little you at these guys, right? Like that's what he's
doing. He's pretty clearly throwing a little [__]
you. He's not saying they're sweeping cuz that would be He's
saying I suspect that these guys might sweep,
which I guess is like also a shot. It's just not quite the same
shot.
And he is speaking conditionally. He's saying, well, maybe I'm
wrong. Maybe they will cover this. He's basically trying to say,
"Oh, good luck not covering it now. You have to."
Which is petty. Okay. Yeah, it is petty. Do I I don't think it's
like some huge shot at your credibility.
I think the virtue signaling, "My friend just got accused of
beating women. You son of a
I think that's also >> You are very sensitive. I know it,
dude. My friend gets accused of beating women and Chud goes live.
>> Oh, he did it. [laughter]
My friend WAS ACCUSED OF BEATING WOMEN. You son of a [__]
Dude, there's no way. There's no That was such a perfect pause.
Let's go. >> Insinuates that I'm going to sweep it up and
not even cover it. Meaning that I'm pro beating women. And he's
like, "Dude, you you're really sensitive about this, man. You're
really sensitive about about defending your friend. That's it's
really up, man. I mean, this is like this guy's like comically."
So, and also he he pretends he has no idea By the way, also another
thing they've been doing is sort of this this thing where they
lie and pretend that Chud was saying that Tom was guilty.
Chud literally never said that Tom was guilty a single time.
The entirety of the coverage is the opposite. Not saying that
Tom is guilty, right? Saying that like, "Hey, actually this evidence
is kind of weak. Hey, this evidence like doesn't actually add
up to him being guilty." Like the entire time. So that's just
a genuine lie the entire time Nick pushes that obvious
incredibly disingenuous lie. >> Why I'm mad at him in his
most recent live stream. I guess he just didn't read this. Also,
I'm not saying go live and cover unverified allegations. I get
Tom is your friend and it's a tough spot for you. You didn't
seem to get that in the stream segment. I think I said on stream
it's hard. You also said a lot of other things on stream, but
it's like the nature of the beast.
H I'm not getting on either of them for leaking DMs. That's That's
even handed both sides. I'm not going to criticize one of them
for leaking DMs and not the other. >> Sometimes we are
the hammer and sometimes we are the nail. That is that is that
is a beautiful statement from Ch. Dude, sometimes we're just
that hammer and sometimes we're just that nail. And even if you
don't want to cover it for personal reasons, understandable,
that would be viewed negatively. I go and then at this point
I just I just tell him the problem and he doesn't even tell me
that I'm wrong. That's the best. My issue was you you were saying
how you hated how much people Oh, so again, this is like timeline
conflation a lot from Nicholas, right? Like in May, Chud was
mad that people were pitting them against each other and then
like the Tommy C stuff happens, a whole bunch of [__]
happens and Chud is getting treated like a piece of [__]
right, by all of these guys.
It's he didn't want it
and then he got treated like the uh like you don't get to come
in the big house anymore, okay? You're kicked out of the big
house. You get to go work in the field. You're you're a field
ninja now. Okay. That's where that's where you go. You don't
get to come in the big house anymore, Chud. All right. It's that's
that's like what happened to him.
And it's it's just really obvious that that's exactly what went
down.
I don't even dude I don't even know that I care that they did
that. They can be friends with whoever they want, right?
But it's just this whole thing of like, oh, you're trying to
say that it's disingenuous that after 6 months or seven months
or eight months of that feeling, like that experience, Chud being
annoyed with you or being angry at you and like taking shots
at you is un unfathomable, unconscionable.
It's just not >> part everything I'm everything I just
told you for the last 50 minutes or whatever the I just run him
through the talking points.
Chud, my issue with you is that you said that you hated how people
pit us against each other. Then you did a >> Okay, that's
that was the messages. Nicholas, what happened between then and
now? What happened between then and now? Well, I know that Tommy
C leaked that you and and apparently Turkey Tom and Willie Mack
all hate Chud. Think he's a total snake. Tell everybody around
you that he's a snake. Okay.
I know you don't disavow those messages. I know that Willie Mack
releases of tweets and videos defaming me and Quimman completely.
You amplify that video and then you dip the out without disavowing
it when you realize it's all lies. You do eventually take the
tweet down way after the fact, but you do amplify the video totally
disingenuously. You take his lies, you amplify them completely
to attack me and Queman.
Okay. What else has happened since then? I feel like there's
been other things happening since then. I can't There's been
other Tommy C. There's been other like bubbling in the background,
but it's pretty obvious that those two things to
Everybody has a reason to be upset with you at that point. Everybody,
you've totally abandoned any principles you have with the certainly
the Willy Mack stuff. I think the Tommy C stuff is just more
mean girl. You guys engaging in mean girl before he did. If you're
just mad that Chud like I guess match tactics for a second, it's
just say so. Just say so. I don't like that Chud did the thing
that we do. Why did Chud do the thing that we do? That's [__]
up, man. segment saying that I am a completely compromised Ethan
Klein sucker. You reg uh you reiterated that you do not watch
my streams but asked if I was loyal to Ethan to a fault and then
you published that segment fanning the flames. When I asked why
you would publish a segment if your goal was actually to avoid
people pitting us against each other, you said you felt ripped
for content and it was unfortunately the only interesting thing
that happened that >> that was a stupid avoidant thing
to say. That was a very stupid avoidant thing to say to somebody
who's a giant wee.
I didn't hide this. I I said it outright. He just didn't tell
you on the stream the other day. He just didn't tell you about
this.
in the segment. By the way, your vague little shot was open with
I'm calling you out, Nick Dioro. Then you started talking about
uh Stardust did. Your response to this was not uh was what was
it? Your response to this Oh, wait. So, and your audience thought
it was about me. Your response to this was it's not all about
you or something. I don't know what issue you think I had with
you. Um but this is why I was put off. I do not think that I
am being irrational here. So, what Chun Logic does here is what
he does every
I do I do like uh that Nicholas in private is totally willing
to admit how Stardust is. That's a W for everybody else. Okay.
In public he'll like amplify her because he likes having take
swings for him. Okay. But in private he's fully willing to be
like listen you I'm calling you out Nicholas Doro and then you
started talking about Stardust did. So your audience thought
it that was me. I don't think that's a tangible thing. Literally,
Chud says he's talking about Stardust, so I don't know. But Nicholas
perfectly willing to admit that sardust >> every single
time I tried to explain to him what the problem was, and he just
ignores me and starts crying.
So, let's hear about it. >> Okay, bro. I understand that.
Let me lay it out. I do have issues with your coverage of certain
topics cuz obviously people want like a big blowout drama between
us. Can Can I just tell this is before he went on vacation? This
is recent. He he he still didn't want to do the big blowout.
All these people want
and I have a feeling that you're very resistant to engagement
criticism. You have blocked a lot of the commentary people over
it. I of course had some latent appreciation FOR >> OH.
OH [__] I'm missing tone indicators. I'm trying to
send DMs and I'm missing tone indicators. Wait, what am I supposed
to think that this person's a total furler who sent this? Let
me let me read this for us. I do have issues with your coverage
of certain topics. Obviously, people want some big blowout drama
between us, but I the feeling I have gotten from you is that
you are very resistant to to engage with criticism and have blocked
a lot of commentary people over it. I of course have some latent
appreciation for our friendship and how you've helped me over
the years. So, what do I do? Some big stream pointing out my
issues with your coverage. I have nothing personal with you,
but my lack of my lack of commentary leaves me to get accused
of sweeping. Yep, that's what I said. that basically Chud described
that he had criticisms and he wants he's basically saying I have
to make these criticisms publicly
or
like I I would be accused of sweeping that's not going to be
in line with my principles
right so I'm you want me to hold my tongue you want me to not
say things publicly but that is that is the two problems that
work against each other here the whole time
>> for our friendship and how you've helped me over the
years so what do I do >> okay okay it leaves me feeling
like I'm biting my tongue sometimes I have a crash out and talk
to some and do fan the flames of wanting us to fight. I get that.
I get that's bothersome for you. You message me behind the scenes
and we don't really resolve anything. Now some of that is on
Chud obviously feels like there are further tensions and pressures
for me to have to have this conflict with you which I resist
and try to continue to do my own thing outside of the EHD slop
cycle which has taken over commentary space. The commentary space
>> me to get accused of sweeping.
Dude, he's terrified of you. Yeah. All the guys in there being
like, "Nick's coping. He's horrified of you."
>> Okay, so this is this is a whole thing where he's saying
what sweeping is. You have a problem with something. You you
do have like principled disagreements with something and you
hold your tongue. That's what Chud thinks sweeping is. So, he's
saying, "I disagree with you with your EHD coverage. I am holding
my tongue and that is sweeping. I get accused of sweeping over
that." Okay.
>> And to be honest, I would be too if if you're the last
people in my audience, who's going to stop you, you know? Oh,
my [laughter] my commentary community is calling you, dude. He's
complaining that you're calling him a sweeper, bro.
He's scared of being called a sweeper.
He This is the most audience captured.
is it bad? Wait, is Nick is Nick saying it's not a big deal to
get called a sweeper or it is a big deal to get called a sweeper?
I think it's probably down to like how much you've been sweeping.
But I just
I think if your if your audience the people who patronize you
or sorry patronize you, who who give you patronage, who give
you donations, who give you money, all this right viewership,
if they think you're dishonest, if they think you're not being
real with them and your whole job, the whole thing you do is
you're the guy who's fair, you're the guy who gives you the the
fair take on anything,
right? That's a problem. Hey, my my audience doesn't think I'm
being honest with them.
It's not that he's scared of them like in a real s. It's like
they he's saying they'll have a real actual
uh like phone to pick with me. Like it will be substantive. It's
not that he doesn't want them saying it cuz they call him a sweeper
all the time. They'll be correct. That's the problem, right?
The problem is they will literally be correct about the sweeping.
I don't He doesn't care if they're going to call him a sweeper
when he's not doing that. When he's just being a normal person.
if they accuse him of sweeping over this, they'll be correct.
That's the problem. Okay? Cuz he he does have problems. He's
described them to you in private. Now, he didn't litigate them
with you in private as much as he should have, but he's described
them to you in
I have SEEN IN EVER, LITERALLY EVER.
YES, he is obviously wait. That's obvious from the messages that
he's saying he needs to hold his tongue for the sake of Nicholas
that it's over his f their friendship that he doesn't say anything
that he doesn't want to do a big string pointing out his issues
with your stuff, right? That's why
it leaves me feeling like I'm biting my tongue. So, dude, I'm
the You're afraid of your chat. It leaves me feeling like I'm
biting my tongue because I have to crash out and talk some [__]
>> Oh yeah, he actually is just totally misreading this
now. Oh, he's totally misreading it. He's totally misreading
it. Listen to what he said. >> Leave me feeling like I'm
biting my tongue. So, Dude, I'm the You're afraid of your chat.
It leaves me feeling like I'm biting my tongue because I have
to crash out and talk some [__] to fan the because
I have to Dude, no. He's saying because he has to bite his tongue,
it leaves him feeling like and sometimes he just crashes out
about it. That he's like been biting his tongue and so he just
he like vents for two seconds and is honest and then he goes
back to being himself again.
It's not that he's scared of his chat. He doesn't want to upset
you.
You're the person. All of Nick's criticisms here are correct,
by the way. Except the person he's scared of and the person he's
trying to plate and be friends with and maintain a relationship
with isn't his chat. He's actually risking his relationship with
his chat to maintain his friendship with Nicholas. And Nicholas
is basically getting mad at him for not being willing to risk
enough, not being willing to sacrifice enough.
And that he's
it's actually insane. The flames of wanting us to fight. Now,
I have to ask, what's the difference between crashing out and
talking so my chat leaves me alone and the banter?
I'm just curious when he
>> he's he's saying he does that for himself. Feels me
leaving like I'm biting my tongue. Sometimes I have a crash out
crash out and talk some and do fan the flames of wanting us to
fight. I get that is bothersome from you. You messaged me behind
the scenes and we don't really resolve anything. So the lack
of resolution is what is upsetting him. Now I think Chud participated
in that lack of resolution. They both did to some extent but
like I think Chud, you know, Nick says, "Hey, I want to talk."
He never gets back to him. I do think you keep following up if
you're Nick and you want that bridge rebuilt,
but I I think Chud is the primary person who let that conversation
not happen. Who left that left Nick on red? >> He says
it's just banttom, mate. And I do banttom all the time, but in
my messages, IT'S I'M SCARED OF MY FANS. I'M scared of my fans.
I have to keep them at bay. I No, Chud did lose subs for his
ice take though. Jakur
Chud Chud is not scared of losing viewers all the time. He will
do stuff and stand on principle and lose viewers over it. But
he didn't want to do this because like he literally is saying
we're friends. I don't want to do that. I don't want like literally
the the out all the outcomes are things I don't want. He wants
to remain friends. He wants to keep the audience. He wants his
channel to keep growing. He wants like all of these positive
things. And he wants I think he wants Nick to like admit that
he was swept a little bit for Ethan Klein as well.
But there's like he gets none of the positive outcomes for himself
essentially if he goes after Nick. So he's like, could we could
we resolve this somehow?
Anyway, uh I do still think that unfortunately
Nick Nick did say, "Hey, let's do this call and talk about it."
And Chud didn't want to do that.
I
I think for Chud the problem is is he's done the thing. Okay,
he's done the thing. This is the worst thing you can do.
It's so easy. This is why the ice thing feels good. Okay.
If I lose viewers or I lose subs because
I have a take that people dislike but I truly believe in it.
It doesn't bother me at all.
If I lose subs cuz I'm like trying to protect somebody else or
I'm doing something I don't even agree with myself. If I am being
disingenuous with my own opinions to my audience and I lose subs
because of that. Holy.
That is just ah it like that is the worst kind of poison, man.
That is like the worst kind of poison in your mind. It's it's
like super deflating. It's super
people. No, we're talking about Chud's ice take. Chud's ice take.
Uh people left over that. Um his audience. So that's I I get
that. And that's I think what he's saying is essentially I'm
having like um I'm having problems doing this. I want to just
talk about my own thing. And now it's like he did he did both
things. He he both sacrificed, you know, his sanity, his principles
a little bit to not criticize Nick and he's still going to have
the big blow up with Nick and and lose subs for it, right?
That's got to feel that feels. That obviously feels I throw the
mistakes so they don't eat me alive.
Dude, Chad, just ignore Dude, you know what you should do, Chad?
My God's honest truth. Me to you. You should block them.
You should block every last one of them. >> Yeah, this
whole this whole narrative about being scared of chatters is
not true. It's It's just very funny. Um I'd say Chud might be
friends with those chatters. They could influence his opinion.
But the thing about being scared of the chatters, that's not
true. And this this whole thing is like a misread.
So whether he's intentionally or unintentionally misreading,
I'm not
Oh, you know what I should have been doing this whole time? I
should have been I should have been copy pasting timestamps for
myself to come back to
Why wasn't I doing this the whole time? Oh [__] Well,
I'll remember the I'll remember the things to look up. Give me
a second. Uh the Oreo stream. Here's a time stamp. This is uh
misreads
second message. Okay.
That's what I would do.
Oh, I have to fan the flames of who want us to fight. I get that's
bothersome for you. You message me BTS and we don't ever resolve
anything.
Feels like there are further tensions and pressures for me to
have this conflict with you which I resist. I try to continue
doing my own things outside of the HD slop cycle which has taken
over the commentary space. Alongside that, I have my own outside
of streaming. I'm dealing with some issues with my channel that
I'm trying to navigate. Honestly, it feels like a
>> So
I
I don't know why he's doing the soy voice for this the whole
time. Just Yeah. More >> communication between us is keeping
up appearances.
Obviously things have >> Nick, by the way, this is how
Nick gets through a bunch of conversations is he just does tone
indicators. He does this all the time. He relies on it all the
time.
Just constantly, man. It's so constant. Do you remember the um
there was like the conversation about Denims and her chat logs
and he's like playing Fortnite and he basically just like trails
off in a sentence. He just sounds confident that like nothing
wrong happened there and he's just like
he just trails off in the sentence. Okay. Doesn't even finish
like disagreeing with the chatter or something. Basically just
trails off. And I feel like people hear that as Nick sounded
confident and it's just like oh well yeah Denims is still wrong.
Denims is still bad.
Yeah. does the self-referential stuff. This guy's being a total
flamco right now. This guy's being a real John Swan right now.
He does this all the time. >> Change. And sometimes it
feels like you're just wanting to see if I'm planning on turning
on you. No, you did. You did turn on me. That's that's what h
you did turn on me. So Mr. You're so sensitive. Mr. It's just
banter. Is a complete chat slave who's terrified of probably
Queenman. If I had to guess, probably Quean. Probably Parry.
Oh, that's that's projection. That's That's giga projection right
there. Uh oh. >> That's insane projection right there.
Oh
I That's crazy.
>> Maybe even Dickers. >> Maybe the entire roster
of people he was talking about how he's still friends with. He's
probably scared of you, too.
>> Yeah. I don't know. Maybe you're not cut out for this
man. So, we keep going. Sorry, I read really fast. I'm already
through all that. I don't think I'm ignoring you. Queman's biggest
criticism of Chud. You're basically like airing out for him right
now.
Like I'm pretty sure this if Quimman had criticisms of Chud,
I think this would actually be the biggest one is that he sweeps
for you and that he was way too kind to you in cases where he
shouldn't have been that he should have been calling you out
and instead of calling you out, he preserved like maintaining
that that bridge with you, that friendship with you over calling
you out. That'd probably be Quimma's biggest criticism. So you're
you're like laying it out for him right now. Thank you. Yes,
Chud was too nice to you.
Same guy who refused to say Perry's name, by the way. I don't
know. It's It's wild stuff, man. >> Returning. I literally
just wish you'd answer any of my messages and we played a game
of Fortnite and talked about it. I'm I'm psychotic here, clearly.
And he goes, "Just leaves me in this place where we really aren't
friends like we used to be and you're spinning off into the Ethan
orbit and I can't really call it out without having a massive
falling out with you." But like, do I even need to call it out?
It feels like you're doing your thing and I'm doing mine. I was
until you acted like I was a comically evil defender who's sweeping
up for Turkey to Tom before I even knew what the allegations
were. [laughter] That's like Yeah. muted. No, it's not muted.
That's you.
>> I got sent a clip around this time. >> It's definitely
not muted.
>> It's definitely not muted. No, it's you. I just Thank
you. >> Invokes Chv's like trying to talk me.
I will say
Chud Chud tries to invoke like my previous relationship a lot
to talk me. It's a little weird given some of his previous relationships.
It's just a little weird. I feel like it's just odd for him to
do, but it's fine. >> Nice. You got me. Ch. >> I
I do think it's just banter. I do think he doesn't really know
what he's talking about. >> Oh yeah. So then I say, "Chud,
we literally had a phone call shortly before the interaction
and I didn't get weird vibes at all. We were chatting about EDHD
and going through talking points. Did I miss something?" "Yeah,
that was months ago, man." And I go, "No, my point was it was
right before the stream thing." I said, "I was so caught off
guard by you saying that I was loyal to Ethan to a fault because
we had spoken about this topic and I didn't realize you thought
that I was a principalist sellout. It completely caught me off
guard, which I think most people would be a bit bit perturbed
at the concept of their friend thinking that they have like they've
lost all morals, all morality."
So up ahead,
um, I interpreted at the time as you being upset that EHD was
a content black hole where no other stories were getting attention
and you were holding me almost personally responsible. To be
fair, I checked it was 54, stream thing was 528. There was some
time in between. I just didn't realize relations broke down that
much in that time frame. So then he goes, "Dude, what's happening?
Fake Discord messages. This is the only thing that I'm going
to say my bad over." I told and when when Chudlo Logic started
doing his whole the big sweep is here thing. I was like, "Bro,
this is crazy. We literally had a falling out yesterday." So,
obviously his little drone started posting it. So,
that is Where are we? Yeah. So, that goes up. I said, "Yeah,
I didn't say anything specific in my Discord. I just said we're
not cool anymore." I shouldn't have said anything. My bad. Uh
I was just blown away when I clicked into your stream to hear
about the Tom and you were just unloading on me right after we
stopped talking yesterday. So, and I apologized for that. He
goes, "Okay." I mean, haha, I was taking some shots, though.
Yeah, it's definitely what I'd call it, but uh like I have to
respond to what I see in front of me. The board, uh thrust was,
why is the podcast on hiat on hold if it's no big deal? I mean,
you could use common sense. I think that you have access to that
ability. That is an ability that you >> The common sense
there is that it's clearly like a tangible allegation that you're
going to pause the podcast for. That's is is Nick not accessing
common
Nick Nick is like he always does this tone thing. Engage with
that. If you see that, you know, somebody gets suspended as CEO
of a company over assault allegations, do you say that's a nothing
burger with no other information with like very little other
information? You just say that's a nothing burger.
>> Yeah, I believe you have.
And then Chud said, "Okay, I mean, haha, I was taking some shots."
Oh, that's the one we just read. Yeah, Chud, I was live. I thought
it was insane. I don't have time to even read the thread. I was
being precautionary. He goes, "Oh."
Oh,
[laughter]
I was precautionary.
What? What? Why?
Or why not just be more deliberate there? Why not say, "Um, I
haven't looked at any of it yet, so I have no idea. I think I'll
pause the halfbaked episode that's coming out tomorrow until
I have time to look into it." Why not just say that?
Like would you just say because the way he checks out is
he says something like suffice to say guys halfbaked is going
to be on hold for like the immediate future like like it's going
to be on for the foreseeable future or something. The way he
says it actually adds weight to it and everybody interpreted
it that way. >> Oh, I'm not saying go live and put them
on blast immediately which is kind of what it sounds like considering
the timeline for this is the next day.
So when would you have wanted me to do that? at 8 am.
I mean, the claims aren't well evidenced anyway so far. I go,
"No, I mean, I was already live at the time." >> Yes. Well,
I think it's Nick. Nick says it's a a betrayal, like a knife
in the back that Chud made the H3 suck comment. And then he says
that because Chud told him, "Oh, actually, I don't like that
we fight. I don't like that my chat pushes me to fight with you."
Right.
I would like to see the progression of that. Was it Was he complaining?
Did he say the H3 Duck thing and then go back and talk about
how that he doesn't like how the chat gets him to fight? That
sort of drives home that it's a joke. But let's see. What's the
Perry tweet? Hold on.
Uh I think I'm going to talk to Becket in a few hours here. Give
me a
What was the Perry tweet? I want the Perry tweet. Give me the
Perry tweet. What is this?
Oh, it's just the same. >> He goes, "Be real, dude. You
know that he won't get hold over the colds for like for this
like it was Idubbbz or Hassan." I go to answer your question.
No, I did not know anything. I didn't even know what he was fully
accused of until I ended stream. I went a lengthy rant on the
stream.
Did he not get a call?
I wish Chud would have asked, "Is is Nicholas lying here? Is
Nich Did Nicholas not get a call from somebody that he paused
the stream and he went and talked to them? Then he came back
and he sounded kind of rattled. So, he didn't have a call from
anybody or what? What is that? I didn't know any I didn't know
anything.
I I do think he knew something.
I do think somebody told him about it. Maybe it was just, hey,
Tom got accused of something really bad. Looks really bad or
something like that >> about uh going in on unverified
claims with Hassan and the furry thing. So yeah, I wanted to
put out the podcast on a whole >> Oh, is he trying to be
Weasley with the
>> Hold on. I didn't even know what he was fully accused
of until I ended stream. I just went on a lengthy rant that stream
and going in about going in on unverified claims with Hassan
and the furry thing.
Okay, that that doesn't make sense. I went on a lengthy rant
on how if you make like rash decisions and and public publish
information or do something without verifying claims, you look
and then without verifying claims, I put my podcast on hiatus.
seems confusing, doesn't it,
guys? Guys, I just talked about how stupid it is to run with
unverified claims.
So, without looking any further, I didn't know what Tom was even
fully accused of yet. I put my podcast on
That doesn't make any sense. That makes no sense, man.
You either knew something. You either got told something that
made you say, "Oh, well, obviously we're going to put it on hiatus."
Or
you made a decision. You can just own it and nobody even cares.
IT'S JUST A WEIRD lie after the fact, that's all. It's like,
it's actually totally inconsequential when you think about it.
Whether he's lying here or not, it's really inconsequential.
He's just like lying to make himself seem correct. I don't care.
But just I It's just such a weird lie. >> Turned out to
be a predator. We had an episode ready to drop today. Okay, man.
We're getting lost in translation here. So, I whipped that back.
I whipped that back and I said I was responding to your claim
and I'm paraphrasing of why would they put the podcast on hold
if it was nothing? So then Chud starts complaining saying I'm
getting a bunch of commentary droolons coming in saying nothing
burger no big deal. So I'm saying it's no big deal. Why is the
podcast on hold now? It's a precaution. So you could assess which
is reasonable. So I agree it's aggressive to put it in the way
that I did. Basically not everything I say about is about you
and but I will say I was expecting you not to cover this at all
to be totally upfront.
So my comment about who will cover this and who won't >> is
a jab at you to be transparent. So, I sent him my initial statement
and I go, "Did this get leaked?" I think I missed a message,
but it wasn't super relevant, but I want to make sure it's here.
Or maybe I didn't. No, I didn't. I don't. So, I I feel like I've
had the correct understanding of this entire thing. Maybe there's
more of a like maybe this is another case of Nicholas missing
something. Maybe Chad on that first stream, maybe he makes a
more
like claim against them.
that I'm missing. Cuz to me, you know how I feel like I do this
a lot where I I'll say like, "Oh, watch. Is this going to happen?
Watch watch this happen." And it's like, I know if the person
I'm talking about sees that, they're going to feel pressured
to do what I would want them to do. There's like a thing that
people do that's like that. You're not claiming something. You're
saying like, "Watch, I think this is going to happen." It's pretty
obvious that's what Chud's doing in a way that like is dickish.
Certainly. I think he had some hurt feelings there probably.
>> I don't think I did.
So, here we are. Um, where was something wrong with the statement
I put out? Um, no, not necessarily, but be real with me, dude.
We're dealing with a different approach to this versus Idubbbz
and Assan. That being said, I know you criticized Willie Mac
Show for spreading unverified. I think I am missing a message.
I do not want to take him out of context. Give me two seconds.
I'm grabbing it cuz that was a mistake on my part. It should
be Chud message 2 or three. Sh message two. Is it this?
Um, yes. This is the one we're missing. I'm sorry. I missed one
ear. I missed the second message. So, >> oh, I don't know
if people have pointed out that Nick stopped a podcast with Dan
for doxing, but then after Tom Tom's video came out, Pigas was
justifying that girl's dox. Another example of Nick not holding
to his principles. Actual weasel loser. Well, Nick never holds
to his principles. Nick will always say Nick doesn't have principles.
Nick has people he dislikes. and what you're allowed to do. You're
allowed to do things to people he dislikes no matter what. And
to people he likes, you have to have principles.
That's how Nick operates. So I do not want to take him out of
context. Um
it was I mean I feel like I can never be critical of you in any
way without getting a message from me. Like you're trying to
keep me on your side. Then it turns out I do have this issue
since May. You haven't said anything to me about it. By the way,
you know, I was literally on Willie Mack show for his Hassan
take like a horrific Hassan take about a furry account yesterday.
Why didn't you on Willie Mack for his horrific and totally madeup
doxing that he published? Why didn't you publicly go out and
say that that was wrong after you publicly boosted it?
Hey,
why didn't you actually go out and go after Willy Mack for the
thing he did to your friend's friend? Like, if one of us published
a totally fake like thing on Willy Mack, if we if we came at
Willy with total lies, I would expect you to get upset about
that. We came at Willy Mack with truths and you got upset about
it. Blade Matt totally made something up about both me and Queman
and Nicholas just lets it go
is very bizarre. >> I caught that jab, too. Then he says,
"Yeah, I saw that. It wasn't pointed at you, bro. Sometimes you're
so sensitive. I know it's tough and whatnot." I said, "Chud,
I asked to chat with you and all this happened. You never got
back to me. I kept the line of communication open. I actually
think I just missed that one message, but I wanted to make sure
I didn't that up. Sorry." So, moving
um, it should be Yes, this is this is the one we're on.
>> Hold on. They're turning on each other. [clears throat]
What is this? >> They all look the same. >> They're
turning on each other.
>> It's this one. No, not necessarily, but be real with
me, dude. We're dealing with a different approach to how
would be handled. That being said, I know you've criticized really
>> Sorry. Uh, Alex Gekcko has been off of like Nicholas's
side for a long time.
I'm pretty sure >> show for spreading unverified. My take
is if it's a nothing burger, I won't cover it. If he's done something,
I will, but I want to wait until um I want to wait because I
think I'm too biased to cover it when it's breaking news. And
then he goes, "Okay, but and this is not unreasonable. He is
getting a lighter touch because he's your friend." I thought
this was obvious,
>> by the way. Yeah, I don't even agree that this is like
a valid criticism. I think I've already said this. I I straight
up don't think this is a a valid criticism.
I thought for anybody this would be obvious.
Yes, it is more difficult to be critical of severe allegations
against >> We'll cover the Becket stuff after this. I think
I'm going to talk to Becket after both of our streams or something.
So, I think I'm planning to do that on stream. So, we'll see.
I need to I need to get through this and then I'm going to cover
Becket stuff. I just wanted my own cut of this video and then
>> get back you've hung out with that's like been your
friend for seven years. Yeah. Like, of course. Of course that's
the case. That's literally why I opened my segment telling you
that was the case when I eventually did my stream. And then he
says, "I'm not trying to catch you out here. Just trying to be
real." I wrote, "I wrote that directly. I am compromised because
he is my friend. I am fully ready to condemn him if he is guilty,
but I do not trust myself to be able to fully separate from this."
I think that a segment where things are unverified will be a
lot of embarrassing coping because I'm subconsciously looking
for excuses. This is what I >> Yeah, I think this is totally
fair. I think Nicholas could easily have just argued this. I
don't know why Nicholas had to go and like do why why didn't
he just argue this and say, "Chud, you're wrong."
Actually, Chud trying to point out that I'm I might be sweeping
because I'm not covering this. No, I'm I'm not covering it because
I like don't feel it's appropriate for me to cover it.
Yeah, I I How did Chud end up winning this? I think Nicholas
is right here. How did Chud end up convincing Nicholas to go
cover this? But I told >> Who is to use Nicholas's projected
logic? He must be scared of somebody if he if he doesn't believe
in something, he's going to do it anyway. He must be scared of
somebody. So why did he cover >> I covered it. So I think
it would be easier to navigate once all of the allegations are
made because they were spoon feeding it and dripping it u drip
feeding it. So he started covering it as it was still being spoonfed.
So nothing he's saying here is actually something he held himself
to. >> Breaking news as things are being drip fed. I do
not think there is any shame in admitting publicly and privately
that it's going to be hard for me to navigate when one of my
close friends gets accused of heinous. I do not think this is
controversial. If Chud logic does, it explains why he has no
friends. That's the reality of the situation. Maybe to delusional
40-year-old,
uh, this is a foreign concept, but for people who actually do
have friends, I think that most, let's see,
I think the issue, well, one of the issues that unfortunately
Turkey Tom's friends make up the vast majority of the space,
right?
That's that's a big problem in and of itself that people go here
and there's a lot of like moral criticism, but Turkey Tom's friends
make up like a ton of the space. So, it's it's very difficult
to find somebody who can't use this excuse. I'd say is one thing.
Uh, there's another thing where Nick has always talked about
how he's the person who holds his friends accountable, right?
I'd say those are arguments from Chud's side that it's important
to hold your friends accountable, cover stuff even when your
friends are are having bad things happen, right? That if you're
willing to cover, you know, anybody getting their DMs leaked,
you're willing to cover basically anything for content, that
probably that should apply to anybody if you're if you're willing
to do that, right? So,
but I I totally agree that you don't necessarily have to cover
something if it's your friend. You might just say, "I I'm too
biased." And like, as long as you don't hide the eventual outcome,
it's fine, right? You should never say, "No, Turkey Tom." You
should never like cut against facts.
But if you just want to say, "I don't want to comment on it.
Looks looks bad, but I'll wait for more to come out." That's
always fine. People will pressure you off of that, including
like it feels like Chud's pressuring to, in my opinion, unfairly
here. I think I said this at the time. I think I think Chud's
pressuring unfairly,
but I just don't understand why that was like that's the criticism
then. Chud is pressuring you unfairly to do this. That's the
criticism. He's not stabbing you in the back. He's not like um
he's not calling you a totally disingenuous [__]
He's he's just criticizing you unfairly. This is not a fair standard
he's holding you to. You don't hold that standard for yourself.
Then then unfortunately at that point if Chud could prove that
you've held that standard that you should cover your friends.
If you've ever said something like that then you're kind of [__]
right? Most of them would understand my
I mean I'm in a different boat because none of you nword I'm
in a different boat because you guys don't even like me anymore.
Although it's different between us. I was more than fair. I have
no issue with you covering it. I was actually looking to watch
your coverage today to see some of it for the first >> but
obviously, yeah, it's hard to navigate. I clicked in during the
great sweep. I I was going to you for unbiased coverage.
Haha, bro. I'm being real as right now. That's not just about
you. None of the Cabal will cover this. This is hilarious. I
am the Cabal. WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE CABAL,
you're talking about me. THERE'S NOBODY ELSE, WHICH HE AGREES
WITH. So when you say the cabal chudlogic, are you talking about
sensitive society? Are you talking about a cheeto? Are you talking
about think before you sleep? Are you you're talking about me?
You man
you man. [laughter] He's fully adopting. Okay. He's becoming
the FFW we always knew he could be. Okay. Ah, you man. I would
be friends. I would not be friends. >> I could I could
visualize his hands. Okay. I could visualize his hands talk there.
He's totally justiculating there. >> Look at this guy if
he begged to get down on his knees and suck my after this guy.
Bro,
>> this is why I always I always see this. He just thinks
he's like way above people. It's very funny.
It's very very funny how he thinks he's just like way way above
everybody else. Why is he being so pompous? When has he ever
not been this level of pompous?
He's literally always been this pompous. He's always been this
pompous. It's like the number one defining factor of who he is.
He's just always been this on the Aiden thing. Even though it
would have been an easy dunk.
I do plan on covering this though. I just want to cover it when
things are all out in the open. Dude, you unfollowed me? Yeah,
I was picked then refollowed. Bro, I was mad.
Dude, the issue here is the underlying tension. Some of which
isn't even about you. I love the vague like, "Listen, dude. Clearly,
I have tons of problems with you, but I hate other people, too."
people see things like that aren't like what they were. I am
a I'm a strange
people want resolution to this tension. They don't want BTS combos.
They want blood. I hope you understand that when you only say
my name and then you that when you only say my name or make a
comment about Ethan Klein, your audience will think it's about
me. That's like so obvious. So it's such a Okay, but that some
of that is on Nick. No, how much of that is on Nick?
What other streamer who has any relationship with Chud covers
Nick, sorry, covers Ethan Klein that favorably all the time?
How how is he going to blame Chud for the perception that Chud's
audience has which includes a lot of Nick's audience by the way
according to Nick right who's who's to blame for that perception
it's not Chud
a cop out to say oh I'm talking about other people bro you name
me to try to get the piranhas off your back you're scared of
your chat so you can't just sit here and say no I I didn't mean
no harm I didn't mean no harm like no you're obviously taking
digs to try to keep them at bay. It's pathetic. Your audience
captured and pathetic.
Um, so then >> I'm going to skip this part. Sorry. I just
I It's not that I can't read that part. It's uh >> hardest
thing earlier. I don't >> leaving it off screen. >> If
this is accurate, so I don't want to >> The way these guys
the way these guys talk about people sometimes, I just like it's
it's really inhuman to me sometimes, man. I don't know. Maybe
I'm maybe I'm going to be like totally [__] over
by people in this space. Maybe I'm the guy who said that. I'm
just like,
h I I'll rant about like those situations and I don't want to
do that. >> shocking
conversation. I don't remember if he says stardust. I remembered
it the other way. But just to be clear, I'm >> it's the
internet. Uh we're rapidly approaching the like the phase of
humanity where literally every human has access to the internet.
Once it the internet used to be the internet because it was like
never serious. It was like a tiny portion of people who were
all terminally online and weird. That's not the internet anymore.
The internet has everybody on it anymore. It's so the internet
has everyone on it. It's It's literally everybody. All of the
people. All the people are here.
This was like an excuse. You You're giving your age away. Junar
Arc, I'm not trying to take him out of context. I think sometimes
that that you think you're doing me a favor. I don't believe
that. I think he's a coward. Uh and it makes the situation worse.
I don't know, dude. We're going in circles here. And I think
we already touched on the more significant issues. So he goes,
"The only way this will be resolved is by a combo in public.
I don't know any other way, but I will be using lethal force
and you will have to defend yourself." I go, "You think the best
course of action is to litigate our DMs on stream and scream
at each other?"
Yeah.
Literally, all of it has to be on the table. That's the whole
point, right? All of it has to be on the table. Don't pretend
you have friends in these spaces. If they can you over, they
will always protect yourself. Um, no. No. I I don't think that.
I think you just need to make good character judgments with people.
And I've not always been good at that. But um I don't I don't
think there's anything wrong with being friends with people in
the space. Dude, friends you over in real life. Have none of
you ever had a problem where friends you over in real life? Do
you guys think it's only internet people who do that? I will
say this is like a little worse is like having work friends and
it's it's like that. It's not like having it's not like having
true friends that you like just met in high school and you've
always been together. or you met in elementary school, you went
all the way to high school together. It's not like that. It's
like your work friends. It's like, yeah, you you literally work
in the same department and technically they could like kind of
sew you in some way,
>> But there's nothing wrong with having friend. It's so
it's so I don't know,
>> you can call it cope. You can call it whatever you want.
The reality is all of the stuff that I'm showing you is just
his words and I'm just showing you what he said. Tell you what,
if you have huge issues with my
I
agree. I think all of this stuff Yeah. I'm just showing you what
he said,
dude. There's going to be
Oh, this is also funny. Yeah.
To be like big time friends with people, right? Be friends with
people and they're old and now it's like this old. It's like,
"Hey, I didn't want to date that girl anyway. She was ugly anyway."
It's like that same kind of cringe. It's like, bro, you It's
like calling your wife ugly.
You married her. Like, what do you your ex-wife? It's like, you
you married her. What the [__] are you? It's so embarrassing.
You're You're embarrassing, man. This 40-year-old loser that
I used to hang out with, that I thought was like the funniest
streamer on all of YouTube, that I always said was the funniest
streamer of all on on all of YouTube. He's just such a loser
and old and old and a loser.
uh my coverage on Tom. When the time comes, I might humor that,
but I won't be subjecting myself to a gay debate on the friendship
allegations. So, there's that one.
Where are we?
did I miss it? Boom.
There it is. Okay, then we're at the tail end of this part. No,
dude. About it all. About EHD, the clubhouse. I don't know what
the clubhouse is. The Cabal, Tommy, Willie Mac Show, Tommy C,
the whole lot. rape mode on. I go, "Oh, okay. You're meing."
Cuz I thought that was like obviously a joke. Which he then said,
>> he's saying, "I want to actually have a contentious
conversation with you. I don't want to have a conversation where
I'm holding back, where I'm not saying what I think or feel.
I want to have this conversation. I want to have it publicly
so we could have it all in the record and then we could go our
separate ways." So there's none of this gay litigating
kind of so you avoid this whole thing, right? This weird gay
litigating that happens with DMs.
>> Yeah. says, "Yeah, it is somewhat. Sorry I didn't pick
up on that soon. It had been a crazy 12 hours, but I didn't know
how else we were going to resolve the contradictions here. I
was under the impression yesterday
that you had no intention of resolving this. I thought that you
were totally fine with just us not talking. So, I didn't know
we were looking to resolve anything. I thought we were moving
on. That's like not what I was that wasn't what I signed up for
in this conversation." Well, yeah, because I don't want a big
fight with you. Well, it sounds like now you do. Uh, and it's
But you're trying to
tell your audience you seemingly always did, but and you're also
not mad about the sub loss, but you also are terrified to fight
with me or something. Yeah, this these uh these contradictions
he thinks he's catching. He's just not very good at it. It's
unironically
I'm getting the impression that he like might have gone through
this stuff with Stardust. Like unironically,
I feel like these are like stardust level criticisms
and I I do expect better from Nicholas most of the time.
I really do.
I really, really do. >> This is really embarrassing. [snorts]
I do appreciate our friendship and what you've done for me, but
I make a jab, give a take, and that's the issue. I don't talk
about you and I get pressed for sweeping. So, this is another
moment where Chud Logic is admitting he's a cowardly who's strong
armed by his audience and he's terri
saying, "Can we have a conversation in public?" He's He's asking
for a conversation in public and you're responding by calling
him a cowardly.
That's odd. That's very odd
because he's he's totally ripped by his audience. He's so scared
of his audience. >> Terrified of being called a sweeper
while constantly calling people
I mean
I don't talk about you and I get pressed for sweeping. Does Nick
not understand that the consequence like the actual sorry the
the
substantiveness of the sweeper allegation is what's bothering
him that he is literally sweeping. He is literally sweeping for
you and that's what bothers him. It's not getting called a sweeper.
He gets called a sweeper on every single thing if he is not willing
to call Turkey Tom a diaper fetishist. Instantly
he gets called a sweeper. But he doesn't do that because he's
not scared of the audience calling him a sweeper. He is scared
of sweeping. He is scared of actually sweeping.
Right. That's the problem.
That's I don't understand what Nick is missing here. I I don't
believe he's this stupid. Maybe it just all has to be intentional
to try to like build his own narrative so his audience doesn't
leave or go to Chud or watch Chud's response. But the obvious
problem is whether or not he's actually sweeping, not whether
or not they say he's sweeping.
>> Dude, and if you're in my shoes, I don't care if you
hate me or like me or what you thought about me before the stream,
but would you not be spinning? Is this not crazy? Why does he
keep saying he's terrified of his chat calling him sweepers and
then keep calling everybody sweepers? The reason why the destiny
sweeper thing was so Yeah, it's um it's
he just I
don't know.
I actually don't know. I I can't make a solid read on this whether
he's doing this like totally intentionally knowingly or if he's
totally on this. If he just
I get the impression that he used to build a lot of his ideas
off of consensus. why he's got his discord and now he's just
got the dumbest people around him and so he's building cont consensus
off of like the wisdom of crowds doesn't work when the immediate
IQ of the crowd is 75
it doesn't happen right you don't get the wis there's no wisdom
in that crowd that you could pull together okay you get 175 IQ
together you've got nothing useful okay so malicious is because
there's an entire kiwi farms of people going after every single
person who's who sweeped for destiny if you if you give them
that label because if you sweep for destiny you're ontologically
evil and you get applied to like defender, uh, nude exchange
def like all that's like every
>> Okay. Um, like I would say this could be true, but don't
you have to Isn't that just like a part of your job? Shouldn't
it come down to like, oh no, I'm not sweeping. This is why I
did this or that. is that
I I'm personally sitting here and it's like I got called a Destiny
sweeper all the time and that concerned me but it wasn't like
I was going to go oh yeah Destiny actually because of that I
didn't do that until I found out a bunch of other [__]
about him. Okay,
like that whole thing with Kiwi Farms I do think his Kiwi Farms
thread was like was like going after people a lot right shockingly
far less after the allegations
than before.
very strange to be honest with you. But um
they they were going after people a lot and that was concerning.
But it's like that shouldn't change your opinion. And I do believe
there's something beyond just getting called a sweeper. Like
you actually need to do things. You need to say and do things
right. It's not just it's not just like anybody could accuse
you of this and if there's no merit to it whatsoever then
like then it it sticks. That's not how it works. Hold on. I This
just made me think of something. Let me find this uh Freddy link
real quick. Yeah, Destiny host another seminar for drama YouTubers
where he explains the tenant media stuff to normies. I'm too
lazy to research this myself, but it seems funny.
I like the concept of Desty sitting me and Tom down for 6 hours
and giving us a college lecture every few months, so I am less
useless when discussing.
I It's just very It's very funny. Okay, it's very amusing to
me. It's very I wasn't even close to Destiny at I didn't know.
I didn't know Destiny. I wasn't a part of that community at all.
I wasn't around that I Dude, I I had nothing to do with those
people at all. Okay. Okay. Okay. That's okay. Okay. Okay. Maybe
maybe maybe.
Okay, man.
>> Okay. We got to finish this video. >> Anything
that Destiny's ever been accused of totally down with it. If
they brand you a Destiny sweeper, you're ontologically evil.
But in this case, it's just like you don't even want to be called
a sweeper for not talking about Ethan Klein. That's like actually
pathetic.
So then I just explained to him my final thoughts. Uh, dude,
>> that isn't the problem. Nick is totally mischaracterizing
the problem again. Totally making this up. Totally lying right
now. Obviously lying. Very sad.
>> The issue is the jab in the tape is that I'm totally
unprincipled and a dick sucker organizing a mass sweep for my
accused friend to shut down people like you. I feel like you
realize why I would take offense to that characterization. I'm
like comically malicious in your interpretation. It's not like
I've ever reached out to you over every Sorry. It's not like
I've reached out to you over every minor comment, which he didn't
push back on, but told everybody was the case. Anyway, I I was
wait, I've seen the two minor comments. Were there Were there
a lot of other minor comments from Chud that Nicholas didn't
key in on cuz he definitely mentioned twice the Nicholas Yorio,
your your Klein comment, and then he mention he apparently brought
up the Pisco stuff, too. confused when you say that I'm a horrible
person because that's what a unprincipled fraud would be is a
horrible person. I didn't know that my friend thought that I
was a total complete sellout. Has Nick even commented on the
claim that Chud said Nick told him not to bring up Destiny for
the New Year's stream? Chud said that's where it started.
Oh, I forgot about that. That he did say that. Yeah,
I don't think Nick has said anything about that. That is a little
interesting. Okay. >> So, I was was bit shocked to have
that information shared with me. Regardless, I'm sympathetic
to you getting it from both sides here as well. I don't really
care. In the future, say whatever you want. So, that was the
way that that ended. Now, there's a couple more things that I
do want to address before I'm done tonight. This is a clip that
he just wanted to him. >> He just lied here. Let me show
you this >> And then I made some comments about him to
Pisco. Do you remember that?
>> Oh, he just lied. made he made some comments to Pisco
about how much Nick blocks people and that I felt >> so
now he's leaning into his audience's talking points here as if
I give a about being called out for blocking. I've been doing
this for like seven years. This is my position. Deal with it.
Subscribe. Don't get the out. I don't really care. >> Okay.
So, that's fine. But was it like a different minor criticism
in the Pisco thing that you reached out were like this isn't
true. Was it like cuz I don't know what else he would have said
about Nick Tisco. would he have called him sensitive or something
like what what was the thing because I'm pretty sure he reached
out is Chud just getting like the impetus for the reach out incorrect
>> but he's trying to lean into the whole blocking angle
>> stranged and guess what I got when that started getting
shared on social media >> you got actually nothing because
you're and leaked the DMs where I told you what I was mad about
if you actually correlate this clip and what he's saying right
here I'm talking about how you said that you don't like us anymore
and I'm surprised that you'd say something like that cuz you
ghosted me since September. So he fabricated this entire angle
that I'm mad about some Pisco conversation. Unfortunately for
Pisco, he's kind of just like a casualty of this conversation
because I have no issue with him. The issue with the clip that
I had is this one >> recorded against my rules. All right,
but it wasn't like anything beyond that. Queman is is Queman
like
your friend. >> Well, you tell me, dude. You've spoken
to him more recently on a voice call apparently. So you tell
me, [laughter]
>> hasn't hasn't Aiden literally leaked that like I don't
know. I'm I'm about to say something I don't have full confirmation
on. I thought Aiden literally talked about how Nicholas was upset
with Queenman. I this is like pretty obvious to everybody. Is
he now denying that he was like upset with Quean and that's what
was putting pressure on this relationship cuz Tommy said it.
He didn't deny it. >> You're both British. I'm told that
Queman comes from your community. That's what people tell me.
>> He No. Perry leaked that from Aiden.
Because you know he's uh unfortunately been two attackers leaks
of mine. He's a Hassan fan. He's gone after all the commentary
guys and they don't like me >> So, I said, "It's kind of
weird to say that all the commentary guys don't like you anymore
because of Queen,
which this could be multiple people as well." But I wrote back
asking, "Hey, why are you saying that I don't like you anymore
considering you've been ghosting me since September? It's so
obvious that this is what
>> Well, all of the I mean, there are other commentary
guys, right? And Tommy's basically said that all of the commentary
guys hate Chud.
So again, Nick, this one is unironically like a collective
and Nick is taking it as just about himself. Again,
>> what I was saying, it's like verbatim, but if you want
to look at it here, it's
the commentary guys don't like me anymore. So I wrote you just
ghosted me.
Like that's just [__] crazy. That's an insane thing
that you did. Um also, yeah, this is just the context of those
messages, too. I said that you haven't answered me since September
because u he hadn't answered me since September just for your
viewing pleasure. Lastly, there's this clip.
>> It's not a safe space. Your friends put a bot on my
server and put my paid Discord on a public website >> in
this one. Should I just What the >> Stop stealing his screenshot.
Discord screenshots now. Stop stealing his Discord screenshots.
>> Now my thing's >> Dude, what the Dude, this is
>> Oh, what the I was almost done with my thing anyway.
All right. So, for that clip, he's telling me that I'm stealing
his screenshots or something. Let me just grab this again. That
sucks.
Is it going to reopen? Oh, it reopened. >> It's not Oh,
dude. >> All right. Just ignore that. >> This guy
>> a safe space. Your friends put a bot on my server and
put my paid Discord on a public website. Oh my god, dude. >> So,
he's I
like at what point do I just have to be transparent about this?
Uh, it's not just for paid people. There are a lot of people
in there who paid nothing and are sitting in there.
I know that. You have to know that, don't you? Shouldn't you
be able to see the size of it is like way beyond your actual
like
And by the way, the way they get people in there
is by mod verification. As in, you join and it says DM a mod.
And then you DM a mod. You whether you pay or not, you just DM
a mod. The mod approves you.
that I He's acting like it is a No, you guys have a verification
process. The mods just approve you. That's it. He's reading this
and he's like Nick Dioro, the guy from the commentary community
is horrified of screenshots, bro. Do you think that I am embellishing
this? your
maybe not your guy, but I think he might even talking.
it's funny. [laughter]
Listen, hypothetically, I hope this Dioro fan who I suspect could
also be a massive Aiden fan is seeing that like
>> maybe maybe get thrown under the bus by Aiden a little
bit here. Okay.
Some guy created a bot,
put it in my paid server,
>> connected it to a website.
>> Massive Dioro band did this. >> This is not a
screenshot. It's a live leak of every message that gets posted
in my paid server of all my paid members supporting my channel.
>> Tons of people in there that don't pay anything. Just
tons of people. He's got like Naku level verification on this.
By the way, Patreon automatically sets this up and YouTube automatically
sets this up. It takes two seconds to set up these plugins. Just
more proof that he's got nothing but total drooling who support
him, right? Like he doesn't have a single person who could run
a mod thing. There's not a single person intelligent enough to
run moderation for a Discord for him that could just set up the
It's This is wild. That was a chat
Yorio is a power user for sure. Oh, you think he's like scripted
this >> in my paid server,
connected it to a website. This is not a screenshot. It's a live
leak of every message that gets posted in my paid server of all
>> this isn't an X. This is a Y. This isn't an X. This
is a Y. >> My paid members supporting my channel. I don't
care if if you're screenshotting it. That's like a Okay, whatever.
They are mirroring my entire server. And you know who? You know
who knew that? Well, Chud here because he's reading a message
where I verbatim say it. Now, this was an
Wait, your people knew it. I was literally sitting here one night
and we were watching them put the pictures of like the the Nicholas
Dioro in your Discord. That happened. I was like literally communicating
with them. I was watching them watch my stream.
I was I was watching. He knew they were literally reacting to
me having the thing up on there and watching my stream and commenting
on my stream.
You should cancel that bot's paid subscription or something
so you can screenshot but uh it but not screenshot all of it.
Also, this is totally if he had like a claim that this was something
that was paid access only like this would be bad. inevitably
well Chud here. He's read >> and also
no Chud would have this would have been before Chud went on vacation.
I don't know when he started doing this, but we were watching
we were watching the site.
that Nicholas Dioro fan I think is
I'm not even going to say >> reading a message where I
verbatim say it. Now, this was inevitably taken down. Woo! Awesome.
Uh I think Aiden spread like a rumor that I was trying to sue
the guy who did it. I don't know if this is like a [__]
position or what. I I don't own Discord. I can't sue you for
>> the Aiden and Nick SCOPS are so tragically like and
and pitiful.
Like, I'm sorry. It's very obvious Aiden is going to do whatever
Nick asked him to do all the time.
Like, it's it's Aiden's only
uh I just it's sad. It's just very sad. >> Putting my members
server on a website. That's stupid. Uh, I just wanted it down
because that's kind of crazy and it's like a like are we gonna
start like individually parsing the guys who give me money next?
Is that the next thing that we're gonna do because you guys hate
me that much? Is that the plan? Like what's what's going on here?
So I was like, "Yeah, dude.
wait. No,
it was He understands that it was just funny to watch him see
about stuff,
Somebody did this who just thought it was funny to watch you
see. That's like it.
That's That's all. >> Oh, you're in a safe space on Discord.
I'm not in a safe space. You Dude, your fans are doing this.
>> Stop stealing his screenshot. Discord screenshots now.
Stop stealing his Discord screenshots. >> He's got it in
front of him and he just lies to you. He just lies to your face
straight away. So that's the Oreo.
>> Oh, if that's a lie, Nicholas, if that is the standard
for a lie, this entire stream is full of lies.
Uh, you he was reading the DMs and misunderstanding them to your
face. Nicholas is misunderstand. He's he's lying about this to
your face when he says that Chud's scared of his audience. When
Chud is saying, "Hey, I feel like I have to I'm walking on eggshells
with you as a friend." He He's saying he's scared of his audience.
No, he's not. He's saying he is worried that you are a sensitive
who's going to freak out if he ever criticizes you.
That's what he's saying. To your face, >> Rodeo. And then
this is the last thing. Unfortunately, this is the only thing
that I can't prove to you definitively because it's entirely
fabricated. Dude, it just didn't happen. But I will preface something.
This is what I'm going to say about this allegation. >> One,
after having been subjected to some deranged [__]
attack against my credibility
whilst I'm on holiday and I'm the spineless one, apparent. How
about addressing the questions people are asking instead of just
calling the [__] What do you mean? I'm addressing
the questions, dude. >> I'm sorry. I was trying to pull
up the clip that I wanted, but I got more of him yelling at his
chat. >> I'm sorry, dude. I'm sorry. I I I actually didn't
mean to do this. My the [__] restart me up. I didn't
mean to put >> That's wonderful. >> Thank you for
the super chat. Thank you, >> dude. He's got to stop being
so sensitive, man.
>> Didn't you also signal boost the Assan Cruz cancel culture
allegation? >> I This is clearly not what I wanted. Hold
on, let me just get it quick. I know where to find it. Um
is planned for the rest of his life. Um that he delayed his video
intentionally to spite on vacation as like a gift to me. Or maybe
he's just horrified of the 14K viewers going to get. Let me just
ease your tensions on this one. I'm not trying to get out of
I'm not trying to hide anything. It's just not what happened.
Unfortunately, it would be really funny if it was true because
that would mean that Chudlo Logic went on vacation for 2 weeks,
which is identical to the amount of time that I couldn't respond
to Chudlogic without over my friendship with Turkey Tom because
Turkey Tom still had to respond to his allegations. So, it is
very funny. Um, and Wait, you did respond to Chudlogic.
Wait, you did respond. You literally to everything that he said
you should do despite saying that wasn't what you believed. You
said you you wanted to wait. You said you needed to wait and
then you like a little totally to everything he said
and you went and did your stream. By the way,
I have repeatedly said and defended the idea that you don't have
to do that. You didn't have to do that. That wasn't something
that was incumbent on you. That's my opinion. But you like a
little [__] to everything he said.
I think you could have just stood on business there and said,
"Uh, obviously I I feel like conflicted and Chud's just like
out of his mind on this one. I disagree with him totally." And
just stand up business on that.
What was the problem?
How how hard is that? That doesn't sound difficult. That doesn't
seem difficult. It's pretty easy. It's >> very funny that
it happened while Ch was on vacation. And I wish I thought of
it, but I didn't. So, that's my position on that. You can believe
it or not believe it. But ultimately, if it was true, I'd be
okay with it. It just didn't happen that way. Turkey Tom was
getting >> He said, "It's the same amount of time I couldn't
respond to Chud because I was helping my friend Turkey Tom."
What?
no it would have been fine if you waited until you came back.
I would have by the way I would have backed the Orio in that.
I would have it's just it's how I feel. I think it's perfectly
fine to not cover it. I until you if you know a response is coming
especially
right I think it's perfectly fine.
Chud Chud doing like a move with the whole like oh the big sweep
might be upon us. You you lose on either side of that. Okay.
That's the whole point of doing a media maneuver is they they
know they've got you. Either you have to either you have to address
it directly and and do what they want or you don't address it
and it like looks bad because of what they said. That's the whole
point of doing like a like some some jiu-jitsu. Okay, it's the
whole point. >> Accused of a various amount of things.
You can go read the Kiwi Farms thread. Uh Sacramento just kept
going all weekend long. That is likely the reason why the video
didn't get released on the planned whatever day it was actually
going to come out because when you keep drip feeding things,
you don't know if you're have to make three videos or one video.
The intention is to make one definitive video and I think any
reasonable person would come to that conclusion. But Chud Logic
is not a reasonable person as planned.
He's almost as unhinged as Ymss. No, dude. Chud Logic goes to
this
He goes to this Vietnamese brothel, okay, every single year.
His fans know that he goes to this trans Vietnamese brothel every
single year, dude. And stupid Rob's Media has come out. I'm I'm
kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. It's a joke. It's a joke. It's a joke.
I make a YMS joke. >> I can tell it was a joke.
You sound mad.
>> it's YMS's stupid movie convent. Sorry. Sorry. Right,
dude. Current Nick just jumped over retro 2022 Nick Dioro. My
bad. I Current Nick just jumped out at me. Sorry.
>> I think it's just frustrating really. It's just frustrating
to witness such >> So yeah, this is it. Chloic leaked the
DM that had no context cuz his chat bullied bullied him into
it and then I had to provide the rest of the content that I >> I
think he gave the entirety of the context. I actually do think
he gave the entirety of the context. I don't think there's any
context that was like super important there that Chud didn't
give. I believe Chud says in his stream, like maybe you could
say, well, we didn't get the non-Chud version of it, so that
prevents people from doing it without like possible like uh distortions,
right? That's maybe a criticism, but I don't believe he distorted
the events there. He said, "I didn't reach out. That's my fault.
That's maybe that's on me." Like Nick asked me to talk and then
I guess I didn't reach out to him. That's that's what happened
in those DMs. I don't think there's something like other than
I guess Nick read those DMs and he's like, "Oh, it's obvious
that Chut is scared of his audience." But I think that's a misread
even.
>> I was perfectly fine with kind of just letting go to
shank me in the back minutes after.
>> I think [clears throat] this is just really Yeah, I
think it's really dude. Why is this different? >> By the
way, I think that one you could consider that one way, but I
think at that point Chud felt like, and this is my my read on
it, he felt like he had sort of lost some credibility with his
audience. You know, Queman's been sitting there talking about
how you are. Chud's trying to build a Chud's trying to maintain
a bridge with you. He's not like he's not letting Queen come
on and talk about you. He's basically kept that at like arms
length, right? and it's making him look to certain bad to certain
people in his audience when he won't criticize you for something
that he's obviously seen some of the the queen coverage, right?
So, he looks bad to his audience. He feels like he sacrificed
there and then you just never ever like sacrificed anything on
your end at all.
Now, is is that fair? I don't know. It's It's all like petty
caddyy to be honest. When he comes out and says when he feels
like hurt like that, when he feels that he's gotten his feelings
hurt, he comes out and goes, "Hey, the big sweep might be on.
You Nicholas, you [__] You bitch."
I think I get it. I get how that's annoying to Nick. I don't
think it's a huge attack on his credibility.
It's like a potential attack on his credibility, but it's even
a stupid one.
It's a stupid one like I disagree with, but whatever.
It's like a potential one. It's like a attack on his credibility.
It's like a trap to make him respond. I think all you got to
do there is go, "No, that's I believe in what I believe."
Yeah. Nick Nick like doesn't understand or doesn't care that
Chud is losing credibility with certain people around him
because of his like remaining cordial with Nick and not calling
Nick out ever. I think I think dude I don't remember what Chud
said. Did Chud call Nick out directly over the Willy Mack video?
I think that's giga sweeping. By the way, if you don't call Nick
out directly for the Willy Mac video, that's giga sweeping that
he did there. Again, I'd have to watch his coverage of it cuz
I know he called Willy out, but I think you have to call Nicholas
out with that video as well. He retweets it. He totally signal
boosts a video that's a complete lie. Totally defamatory. Right.
Chad is saying that he will sweep for Tom the same way Nick sweeps
for Ethan and Willie.
Well, Chud is Chud is literally saying I am sweeping by not commenting.
That's what he's saying in those DMs. I'm sweeping
and I don't like that you are putting me in a position where
I have to sweep for you.
So, can we talk about this? Can we do something about this? Could
you talk to Quean? Can you like get this resolved? Because I'm
sweeping for you by not acknowledging it. That's what he's saying
to Nick and Nick doesn't really care. It seems like
uh well he said he wanted to skip that one cuz it was petty community
drama. No, it was one of your friends just lying about other
people. >> I was reading through the Reddit post and people
were like, "Dude, Chud does this to Nick all the time. Why is
this one different?" It's like, "Yeah, because you think I'm
an unprincipled offender sweeper."
>> Sure. That's like a really that's like a onlogically
evil position to be in. So ultimately, what what does this mean?
What does this mean for the channel? After this, we're going
back to covering trending news coverage. Uh, this community is
gonzo. No remorse. Same thing I said during the Cassavo Edwin
stuff. Uh, I'm never talking to Chad Logic again. I think warranted.
I think that's a warranted position that I'm having. Um, and
yeah, that's that's probably the last time I will ever >> I
think he basically left out, by the way, all the stuff after
that bait conversation where Chud's getting sort of like
maligned by some of those people. Willie and Willie is coming
into um to Tommy's chat lending credence to all the things Tommy's
saying. Nick doesn't do anything about that, right?
Ch is salvo. I It is a little Yeah, that is a little bit of a
web there, isn't it? Chud's like Chud's just like Salvo. He's
just like Edwin. He's like a totally degenerate freak who who
like takes advantage of mentally ill people all the time and
doxes people. He's like those guys, right? He's like those guys.
Yeah, there's a whole bunch missing